では よろしくお願いします
［拍手］あの できるだけ話を早く終了したいと思います
これからいろいろあのー
プログラムがございますので
えーと あの 今日はお釈迦様のあの
えっと まあなんでしたっけ？あの
祝うというかね まあお釈迦様のお誕生日の成仏の涅槃のお祭りです
であの 時間があった時間から来た方はね
まあいろいろあのー 大御師のことを聞きたくなって来ましたけどね
で あの お釈迦様っていうのは
やっぱりあの不思議なことで
あの 人類の存在なんですね
だからね あの方々はブッダはネパールで生まれた
ネパールで生まれた すごく怒って
もうおかしにというかね
かなり宣伝するんですけど
まあ私たち仏教徒から見れば
だから別にっていう感じなんですね
なぜならば なんかお釈迦様はどこかの国の人というふうに感じませんよ
ブッダっていうことっていうのは
私もなんか自分と同じ人間として感じるんですね
で 誰でもお釈迦様は外国の人だっていうふうに思うことはね
まずないと思います それがお釈迦の不思議なところなんですね
それからブッダの教えっていうのは
すごく簡単には理解できないんです
理由は まあ人間の知識じゃないなんです
そちらには大きな問題がありまして
なかなかブッダの教えはまあ理解に難しいということになっちゃって
まあ勝手に自分たちに理解しやすいように仏教は変えちゃうんですね
まあそれがよくないということで
私が仏教を教えたものは
いくら難しくても そのまま純粋に世界に紹介しなくちゃいけないということで
世界といったって日本だけでしかできてますし
で 私が死んでからでもね
私は行った言葉をね 他の外国語にもでもして出せば
だいたい日本語で書いてる本なんかは他の言語ではないんです
その内容 まあ他の言語で英語の本っていうのはね
結構出てますけど 日本で日本語で初めて私の名前で出してる本の内容っていうのはまずないんです
そういう見方もなかなか難しくてね
学者の方々にもなかなかできなくて
そういうことだから 私はお釈迦様が何をおっしゃっているのかって
皆様に紹介しようとは頑張ってます
いろいろ言われていますけどね
それには 言われてることは全然気にもしませんが
あの 伝統的に間違った間違っているものを言いなさいよという話なんですね
今までの考えは壊すなよと
だから今まで臭いものを食べてるんだから
それ臭いって言うなよという話なんです
まあ今日はね 皆様大変
あのスタッフの方々も
あの  1ヶ月間ぐらい まあいろいろ準備
準備 準備ですごく苦労して
まあ夜ずっと遅くまで
ゴータマ精舎でもね まあいろんな準備をして
で 今日もたくさんの坊さんがたいらっしゃったんだから
その食事の用意もね したりとかね
まあむちゃくちゃ苦労して
このウェーサーカ祭りをね
実現するようになりましたし
それから皆さんはもうね
結構忙しいのに あの まあ土曜日ね
他のところへ行って遊んでもよかったのにね
それでもせっかくこの祭りに参加してね
まあそういうことで お釈迦様からの何かプレゼントをしなくちゃいけないんですね
だからまあ 私はお釈迦様の代わりに
そのお釈迦様のプレゼントを皆様に差し上げたいと思っています
まあ代表にはならんだけど
ただまあ手渡すだけです
それでお釈迦様のプレゼントっていうのは永久的に役に立つものなんです
で 私たちのプレゼントにはかなわないというか
プレゼントお釈迦様のプレゼントはかなわない
どうしようですかね もう永久的に人間の役に立つものなんですね
はい これはお釈迦様のマハナーマというお釈迦様の親戚の方がいて
いとこですね 王子ですけど
彼との対話から取ったんです
質問は 私たちは生きる上でいろんなことをやっているが
どのように生活すればよろしいのでしょうか？ということのいい質問なんですね
ブッダ答えるんです マハナーマ
あなたのどのように生活するべきかという質問はとても良い質問ですよ
私たちもね 現代の方々もよく聞く質問でしょうし
大体若い人々もね よく聞く質問で
学校の子供たちもね どう生活すればいいんでしょうかとかね
その疑問を持つんですよ
それはとても立派な疑問なんです
だからこのマハナーマ王子がね
人間はどう生きて生きればよいのかという質問がね
聞かれて お釈迦様がまずいい質問だよと言うんですね
皆様も今日からどう生活すれば良いのかという質問を皆様も一人一人で持ってください
何の疑問もなく生きていたらまずいんですよ
ただね 朝起きてご飯食べて
皿洗って 歯を磨いて着替えて
仕事に行って帰って また同じことをやって
で これで毎日忙しいんだから
まあ全然気づかないんだけどね
しかし この毎日のまんまのやっていることをやってやりながら
人間ってただそれだけでいいのかいと
女性の方々はね 掃除 洗濯
子育て それだけで十分でいいかい
人生は 男性にしてもね
まあ仕事だけ 朝行って仕事して帰ってゴロゴロと寝ていて
また朝起きてまた仕事に行ってとかね
それで男性というのは早く
老りますからね 早く衰えますからね
で それで敗食すると もう体も心も全部ボロボロ
もう何も残ってないんですね
だからそれでいいのかいと
何かやっぱり人生に醤油ぐらいかけておかないとね
もう塩コショウでもかけてみなくては
そのままではつまらないんです
だからまあ人生にね まあやっぱり
野菜ね もう茹でて食べてもね
やっぱり塩コショウをかけた方が味が行きだしますよ
そういうことで どのように生きるべきかという質問にお釈迦様が答え出します
まずお釈迦様は ではこのように頑張ってみることですと説法するのです
で 今日はこの七十一 十一の項目を紹介します
まず五個の項目があって
ポイントがあって それを実践するためにまた六の項目
ここがあります 覚えやすいんですけど
1 サドゥーコマハーナマアーラッタコーホーティのアッサド
信が身につくように 不審者にはならないように
まあ不審者といえばちょっと怪しいんですけど
あの信があって生きてほしいんですね
まあどんな信でしょうかね
で 仏教でいう信という漢字をあえて使いますけど
これをパーリ語でサッダーというんですね
あの日本語訳すると信仰と訳しますけど
まあ別に悪くはないんだけど
あの まあ信仰のこの意味は私はあまりまだ調べてないんですけど
あの 信じるっていう意味じゃないんですね
信じるっていうことは
まあバカ以外はね バカという証拠なんですよ
で 信じるっていうことではなくて
じゃあ信じないことの反対は何かというと疑うんですね
それで良くないでしょ？何でもなんか人のこともちょっと疑って
家族のことも本当にこいつらはどうかなとかね
そうやって人のことを不審に思う性格がまず良くない
だから微妙な意味 高くて信じていいわけでもないんですね
どうしますかね じゃあ
まず我々はまあまあ 誰も疑いの目でね
不信の目では見ないということで
まず頑張って それからお釈迦様が言ってる信サッダ―っていうのは
物事を調べて自分で納得することなんです
わかりやすく言えば もう何でも何を信じなくてもいいんですけど
そのなんであなたはこれこれ信じますか？と聞いたら
まあこういうわけだよ
何か理由があればよろしいんです
で 仏教でいうのは確信
しっかりと調べて信じなさい
そういうことが仏教で信と言うんですね
だから あの鵜呑みにすることの反対なんです
鵜呑みにする人間ではなくて
まあ一応このことどうなっているんですか？ニュースで流れただけで
はいはい その通りだとね
それはダメなんですよ
例えばね テレビなんかは何かあったらもう徹底検証しますとかね
徹底分析します よく徹底分析するんですね
30分ではなくて 10
分ぐらいで何も言ってないんですね
だからそうやって言葉だけ振り回して人黙ってるんです
最近出てきたのはね あの竜巻のからくりを徹底研究しましたと
私もまあよく徹底研究するだろうとという
変な目で番組見たんですけど
何のこともないんです
初めからこれぐらいのこと知ってるだろうと
で どうやって竜巻が起こるのかという条件 4つぐらいありまして
それは NHK でもどこでもだらだらとこういうこと
こういうことやとかね
と書いてあったし で それだけのことにまた 30 分かかって
人を馬鹿にするのもいい加減にしなさいという感じになりましたけど
そういうふうに この言葉にあまり乗らない方がよろしいんです
で 特に人の言葉っていうのは危ないんですよ
私はすぐ乗ってしまいます
だから私の言葉に気をつけてください
乗せてみようかなと思ったら至って簡単です
自分の理性もね 使って考えた方がよろしいんですね
これは一般的な信 これはお釈迦様のいとこに教えたものだから
もう兄弟みたいなもんでしょう
お釈迦様よりちょっと年上なんです
マハーナンダさんが ですから
かなり丁寧に仲間で家族の中で大事なことを教えてるんですね
あの釈迦族の人々はみんな仏教徒でしたから
ブッダを徹底的にもう信仰していましたし
だからお釈迦様もね 人間の中でね
仏教になってくると 釈迦族の人ならね
まあ信じなさいよと 例えばこの仏教で出家する場合は
他の宗教で修行をやっていたならば
出家一発で認めないんです
まず 3ヶ月間見習いしなくちゃいけないんです
見習い修行は結構厳しいです
見習いしてお坊さんたちチェックするんですね
心の中身を 仏教は怖いんですよ
人の心の中の中まで仏教から読める
だから本当にこの人は素直で真理知りたい人か
あるいは何か腹黒い気持ちで出家しようと思っているのかどうかね
あるいは一時出家して
一年ぐらいでもう減速して
ああ 仏教とは一応私は一年間もやってましたからとかね
そういうふうに仏教に邪魔する目的でやってれば
それをちょっとヶ月の間で調べてみる
しかし お釈迦様は例外として
しかし 釈尊の人が たとえ極端な邪見持っている人であってもね
出家するなら出家させなさい
あの人々は人を裏切りませんと
いうふうに それぐらいお釈迦様は信頼されていた面目なんですが
だからお釈迦様がこの人には仏教の教えをちゃんと教えているんです
とにかく次に行きましょうか
精進する人間 番目 アーラッダビリオアーラッダコーホーアーラッダコーホーティノクスイと
精進努力する人間になるように
決して怠け者にはならないように
これ大事なことなんですね
我々の心が本来怠け者なんですよ
皆様方 いくら勉強したっても
これは怠ける方法を学んでいるんですよ
結局は便利でやりやすい
生きやすい方法を探してるんです
機械 道具作ったりして怠けを応援しているんですよ
人間なら歩くのは当たり前なんですけども
車作るんですね もう電車作るでしょうに
だから便利や便利やっていう便利イコール怠けなんです
例えば自分の手でキャベツのみじん切りできるならば
自分が能力あるっていうことでしょう
あれでカッターがありますから
スライサーどんなアホにもできますね
均等にみじん切りすることが
だからこれが便利だっていう場合は
やっぱりその中で怠けの思考が入ってるんです
だから人類誰でも怠け者なんです
それがこの脳の開発に邪魔なんです
怠け者だから機械は作るんですよ
例えば計算学ぶと 本当に計算上手な人になりたいと思ったら
そろばん習っていいのかい？そろばんが上手な人はもうたちまち計算してくれますけど
もしそろばんを使わずさっさとできるならば
これで脳の能力が上がっているんです
だからこの怠ける方法よりは
怠けない方法で我々の脳が開発するんです
で スライサーカッター使わないで包丁で均等に薄く切る
キャベツを切ってみようではないか
できるようになってくると
脳がある程度でなんとか能力を身につけているんです
そういうわけで できるだけ道具使わず生活してみようかなと思っちゃうと
道具を少なめにしようかなと思っちゃうと
結構脳が開発します 何でも道具にしちゃうと怠け者ですね
そこで私の師匠がね すごい忙しい方で
毎日何か用事があるんです
毎日村の信者さんの用事やら
国のことやら いろんなことがある
しかし メモ帳がないんです
そういうどんなお寺でも
信者さんがいろいろ法事とかね
一周忌とか あれやこれやとか言うでしょうね
それはかなり前もってお寺に言うんですね
日にち決めなくちゃあかんだからね
お坊さんたちも呼ばなくちゃいけないし
どんなお寺でもあの このカレンダーみたいなものがあって
売っているし 時々製本も配る場合もあるし
そちらでまあ全部書くんですね
一年の いろいろ要約 あの私の師匠は時々製本からもらうものがあるので
そのままあるだけで何も入ってないんですね
なので私たちはそれを落書きのために使う
そこで長老がこの理由は言うんですね
そちらに書いておくと能力が衰えますよ
全部頭で覚えてるんです
一年のスケジュール 時間も場所も全部
ですごくお年になった時でも
それだけはやらなかったんです
だけど 私みたいに明日何があるかわからないんです
随分能力でしょう で そういうわけで
この便利グッズね 今はね
携帯でもスケジュール書けるし
便利ありすぎでしょ それであの能力が減るんですよ
それね 覚えておいてください
ですから お釈迦様がこの俗世間的ではなくて
この心理学的に人間が怠けないようにと頑張った方がいいんじゃないかな
だから皆様も今日から怠けないことに
頑張った方がいいんですね
今まで道具使っていたのに
道具使わないことをちょっとやってみようかなとかね
例えば線を引く場合はどうしても定規使ったりする
まあ定規使わないとでもね
じゃあ描けるのかいと
これ何回 何回 回でも回でも一回でも書くともう書けますよ
それって能力でしょ ハサミでね
布とかなんと切る場合はね
まず メモの線を引いてからやるとまっすぐですけど
ではそうなく切ってみるとかね
そういうふうなところからもうちょっと自分の能力向上することに頑張った方が
いいと思いますよ  3番目の項目は
ウパッティサティ アーラウィコティサティ
ムッタサティ 気づき いわゆるサティですね
がある人間になるように
気がつかない不注意の人間にはならないように
このサティはヴィパッサナー瞑想として紹介していることで
これは瞑想というよりは智慧の鍵
扉なんですね 何が起きているのかと
ずっと目覚めた状態でいることなんです
自分の周りで何かが聞こえるんでしょうか
何か見ているんでしょうかとか
何を感じるのかどうかね
いつでも目が覚めた状態でいるんです
不注意はダメなんです
そういうのの脳の開発なんです
人間持って生まれた能力はもう役に立たない
次元破ってほしいんです
で 金儲かるぐらいは誰にもできます
家を作ることっていうのは誰にもできます
学校に行って勉強してから仕事をするってことは
これどんな人間でもできることでしょう
これには全然自慢にならない
私は学校を卒業しましたとか
今仕事をしていますよとか
そんな自慢すること何もないんだからね
だからこのお釈迦様が言うのは
これは一生大事な宝物になる方法で
気づきを保つ いつでも物事に周りに起こる出来事に気づいている
目覚めている そうすると脳がすごく動いて
どんどんどんどんレベルが上がっていくんですね
それは瞑想にも使う方法なんです
この先の反対はもったいさきというんですね
もったいさてというのは何が何だかわけもわからなく
そのまま生きている人々のことなんです
ああそうですか そうです
あ 気づかなかったとかね
いう感じで みんななんか酔った状態で生きているんですね
酔っ払っちゃって何が起こるかわからない状態で
それだけはやめてください
いつでも目覚めた状態でいてくださいというのは 3番目のアドバイスなんです
次 集中力 サマーヒトアーラディコホーティノーアサマーヒコ
集中力が現れるように励む
心が混乱した状態の人間にはならないように
よく集中力の訓練しなさい
この集中力っていうのは
大体我々の脳にはないものなんです
脳は生まれる時はもう一応ハードワイヤリングして
いくつかの基本プログラムをインストールして生まれるんです
その基本プログラムというのは
まあとにかく生きてみなさいだけなんですよ
危険を察知して生きてみなさい
だからこの脳がバラバラ動いた方が
いくらか便利なんです
だから生まれる時は我々の脳がバラバラ動くようにもうプログラムされてやります
これで脳は開発しないんですね
生まれたまんまの脳の能力
脳の能力でまあ死んでしまいます
死ぬ時は能力はほとんど下げています
上が下がっています 理由はまあ神経は壊れますからね
細胞も死にます だから違うプログラムをお釈迦様が推薦するのです
集中力を育てて 同時にたくさんことをやるんじゃなくて
一つのことを集中してやってみると
脳のあらゆる部品の仕事を一つの仕事に合わせてピンとすることなんですね
それまた脳の開発のプログラムでもあります
5番目 パンニャーワーラーディコーホーティノードゥパンニョ
智慧の人間になるように
無知の人間にはならないように
智慧の当たり前なんですね
誰も無知な人間になりたくはないでしょう
でも我々は結局無知なんです
で なぜ無知かというと
まあ人を言ったことをそのまま鵜呑みにして理解して
それを から考えたりする意味がないんですね
それから何でも主観で見る
この主観で物事を見ることはどうにもならないことなんですね
自分が見ることを考えることは
どこ見たても主観なんです
自分の 自分の主観は真理ということにならないんですね
だから頑張って頑張って物事を客観的に見る
これ結構難しいんだけど
頑張ってほしいんです
客観的に 子供が何か言ったらお母さん嫌だからとか言うんじゃなくて
頑張って じゃあ子供の立場から見たらどうなるのか
お母さんは嫌ですが この要求はじゃあ子供の立場からどうでしょうか
では 第三人者 三つの人の立場からどうでしたか？親の立場
子供の立場 他の人の立場からどうでしょうか
それからでは一般論としてどうでしたか
その 4つぐらい入れてみると
難しいけどやりたくないでしょ
子供が何かこれ なんとかなんとか要求すると
嫌ですよ お母さんが嫌だからやめ
ダメ はい それで話終了ということになりますけど
そんな怠けの生き方ではなくて
もうちょっと客観的に見てみる
それで脳が開発されて知恵が現れてくるんです
知恵っていうのは面白いんですよ
例えば子供が何か何か欲しがっている
まあ子供から見ればまあ面白いだろうと
母親から見ればこれはダメですよ
第三人者から見ればどうなるのか
じゃあ人間として見れば
子供が要求するものが与えるべきかと
例えば漫画買ってくれ
子供は読みたいだけで
母が余計なことをやりたくないと
自分の小遣いで買いなさいと
だけど円しかそれでなんだらかんだら買いましたから
お金ないんだよ で 子供もまたいろいろ言ったりするし
だから 第三人者の立場はどうでしたか？と
世間の立場から見ればどうでしたかと見ると
なんか心が 違うことを発見するんですね
物事に対して感情的になる必要はないんだと
イエスとかノーとか正とか正しいとか間違っているとかね
どうでしょうかねとかね
いろいろ立場があるでしょうね
でも一つも正しくないんだよという風に
なんか知恵の方が開発されていくんですね
最終的には仏教が教える知恵
知恵がありまして すべて無常であること
苦であること 無我であることを発見するんですよ
それが知恵なんです それでこのアーラーデコという言葉が出てきたんです
アーラーデコっていうのは
まるまるを好みになる
まるまるを目指す人間になってください
だからマハーナ文字で言ったのは
いきなりはい 信仰を作りますって
こんなできるわけないでしょ
確信ある人間になりたいなぁとかね
なってみようかなとかね
そういう方向を目指してほしい
集中力ある人間になりたいなとかね
その心の生き方の方向性決めてください
まず道を決めてください
それで 5つの条件を教えたんですね
だからいきなりそうなりなさいってなれるわけないでしょ
知恵がある人間になるようにと
いきなり知恵が現れるわけじゃないんですね
だから自分の人生の方向性を決める
知恵を開発する人間になってみる
それに主観を抑えて 物事を客観的に考える
いうふうに その好みになってしまえば
人生が変わるのです 知恵は主観から離れて客観的に観察する理性から始まります
例えば一番難しいのは知恵でしょう
だから知恵っていうのは理性から始まりますよ
理性ぐらいはね 難しくないでしょ
まあ難しいですけど 時々この何も問題が起きていない時
物事うまくいっている時
皆さんも落ち着いて物事を考えられるでしょ
大変なことが起きちゃうと理性が失っちゃいますね
地震が起こると 津波が来ると
竜巻が来ると まあ理性のひとかけらもなくなっちゃいますね
一番必要な時なんですけど
会社 仕事 クビになっちゃうと
いきなり理性がなくなるんですね
だから時々我々は落ち着いている時
問題が起きていない時
理性というのはありますね
そこをよく覚えて いつだって理性保ちますよというふうに
理性が欲しいじゃん そしたら理性を持つ人間になるぞ
そこから始まると 知恵がじわじわと現れてきます
これで五つの項目が終わります
で パーリ語で覚えやすいんですよ
サッダ サティ サマーディ
アーラッダ ヴィリヤ パンニャ
サッダ サッ サッダ アーラッダ
ヴィリヤ ヴィパッサナー
サティ サマーディ パンニャ
サッダ アーラッダ ヴィリヤ
って五つなんです はい
それからマハーナの王子に対して特別なブッダの技を教えているんです
この五つを育てるために六つの方法があるんだよ
さらにね 実践した方が良い方が六つあります
一番 タターガタアヌスレイヤーイティピソバガワという文章ですね
阿羅漢サンマーサンブッダ
如来のことを念じてみなさい
ブッダを念じてみなさい
どういうことですかね
それが なんかお釈迦様の普遍性
科学性 これでなくなったでしょ
ブッダのことを念じなさいと言ったら
なんか自分の宗教を信じなさいということと同じと感じるでしょう
これ違います あの日本でも念仏ということがありますね
あんなものじゃないんです
日本の語である念仏の元はここなんです
お釈迦様がおっしゃった言葉なんです
如来を念じなさい 如来っていうのは真理に達した人
誰でもいいんです 真理を発見した人
悟った人 この場合は 如来というのはお釈迦様のことかもしれませんだけど
この文章があるんですよ
どうやって念じるのかと
ほとんどの皆様覚えているんでしょ？イティピソバガワアランサンマーサンブッダウィッチャチャーナサンパンノスガトローカヴィドゥアヌットロプリシダマサーリプティサッダデーヴァマヌッサラナブッダバガワという
ここの四つの能力
それが身についてるんですね
だから個人を褒め称えるんじゃなくて
この人間に達せられる
すごい能力のこと だから我々も人間の能力を観察すると
なんとなく自分もそうなりたくなるんですよ
それって面白い心理学的な働きなんです
例えばテレビでね 12歳のプロのピアニストがいるんだよと
テレビでニュースやら番組見ると
まあ3歳 2歳ぐらいの男の子とか女の子を持ってるお母さんもね
うちの子にもピアノを習わせてあげようかなとかね
これは3歳で始めた方がいいやとかね
思っちゃうでしょ それはなぜかというと
この12歳の男の子が今テレビで見た
だからね 見事に丁寧な演奏して CD も出していて
まあすごいんですね 見てみるとちっちゃな子供なのに
よくやるんですから どう見てもまあ完璧なプロである
そんなちっちゃな子供は大人顔負けのプロみたいな
やってくると もう年取ってる私たちから見ればいいなと思っちゃうんですよ
なんていい子でしょうかとかね
だから自分にも子供がいれば
うちの子もこうなってこうかね
かっこいいんだけどと思っちゃうでしょ
これ悪くないんですよ
だからブッダだったらブッダの能力を念じてください
この上のない人間になってしまいますよという話なんです
そこでブッダの能力ってね
イティピソヴァラアーラハン
すべての煩悩をなくなった阿羅漢であり
サンマーサンブッダ 完全に悟りに達しています
だから完全に悟りとは初学者だよ
聴覚者だよと思うと 俺もこのままではダメやと思っちゃうんですよ
ヴィッチャーチャラサンパンの知恵が完璧で
道徳は完成しているっていうのは私の解説で
注釈書はもうちょっと違います
ヴィッチャーっていうのはどうせ知恵の三つの知恵ですけど
チャラナっていうのは瞑想して得た神通能力のことなんです
注釈書によると 私はチャラナっていうのは道徳だろうと思っているんです
どちらが正しいかよくわからないんです
で 私は正しいわけじゃなくて
私は理解しやすいという生きしこうで
チャラナは道徳であると
で 解説はします まあどちらでも構わないんだけど
お釈迦様は知恵と道徳が完成している
あるいはお釈迦様が知恵と瞑想して
あらゆる超能力を全部身に着けているんだよ
すべての超能力を身に着けているんだと聞いたら
まあ一つ二つぐらい自分もやってみればどうなるんでしょうかということになりますよ
本当に能力を開発する方法
仏教にあります それからヴィッチャーサンパンの姿
やることは完璧にやり遂げる
中途半端じゃないんです
途中だけじゃなくて パーフェクトに行う
ロータウィドゥ 生命のことは知り尽くしているんだ
アヌットロクリシャダンマサーリプッタ
人間を指導するにあたっては
この上のない能力を持っているんだ
こういうふうにブッダの出来事
ブッダどうやって王様を調教したのか
もう乱暴な人にどうやって教えたのかどうかね
他の宗教の方々にどういうふうに教えたのかどうかね
いろいろ調べると すごい心が変わるんですよ
まあ時間なくなりますけど
ちょっとしたエピソードを言います
ある有名なバラモン系の二人がね
家柄は違うんだけど 二人もバラモンの伝統のトップの8人の家族に入るんですね
一つはワセット系で 一つはバーラン系だと思いますけど
それでもうバラモン教になってくると
もうそちらが一番権威のある家柄になります
が この奥さんがおそらくワセット系だと思いますけども
ちょっと覚えてないですけど
ブッダを信じる これまずいんですよ
バラモン教の本山である
ヒンドゥー教では本尊といったり
お寺ではなくて人間なんです
ヒンドゥー教は日本の宗教とちょっと違います
人間なんです だから このバラドゥーゼバラモンがバラモン教の本山のひとつ一人なんです
奥さんが仏教徒になると困るでしょ
これ しかし よっぽど気に入ったお子さんやと思います
逆に そこで食事を用意しようと食事を持っていたら
ちょっと足がこけちゃったんですね
こけたら 3回ナムを足すと
ボートを笑うとサンマーサンブッダって読むと
で 食事を用意したり それ宗教的なしきたり
儀式でもあります これはバラモン教しきたりもやりながら信仰しているんですね
言ったら怒鳴りつけたんですね
このワセリという言葉を使ったんで
ワセリっていうのはこの
不可触民族という意味なんですね
バラモンの奥さんにそんな言葉を言うと失礼なところなんですよ
あまりにも怒ったんです
って お前なんか何やと
この家 あの釈迦はあの髪の頭のハゲている
チャンラーラっていう不可触民族の宗教をやっている
あの法レスを信仰して何やこれ
あんな人っていうのはね
どうったことないでしょうと
私なんかすぐ言ったら
私のようなね もうすごい知識人で
バラモン教の本山である私のような人いたらね
すぐ倒してみせますよ
あんなアホ 言ったら このバラモンの奥さんが
ああ そうですかね じゃあやってみれば
やってみればどうですか？言って
あんた ブッダをね ブッダに勝てるかないか
だから叱ったことには
この奥さんが全然気にしていないよ
どういうそう言ってやってみてということですよ
言ったら ああそうですかと
奥さんに馬鹿にされちゃったんだからね
あんたみたいな人はね
相手にもならんよ ブッダの
と言われて もうさらに怒ったんですね
奥さんにも無茶馬鹿にされちゃって
行ったんです ブッダに行って質問するのです
一つ一つを教えてちょうだい
何をなくなったら楽になるの？何一つ一つだけ教えてください
この一つをなくしたら楽になる
殺すならば殺すべきたった唯一のものを何かと教えてください
心が安らぎ得る幸福になるものを何か
これだけ殺しちゃえば
あなたは完全に安らぎだして幸福になりますよ
この一つの項目は何だとワサワサと一つにしちゃったの
この人は答えられないだろうと
おそらくこのバラモンも答え知らないんです
質問が作っただけで お釈迦様は何のこともなく
まあこうだんじゃっばーす完成
怒りをなくしなさい 楽になりますよ
それから怒りって ただこれだけ殺しちゃえば完全に幸せになりますよ
言った途端 びっくりしちゃったんですね
自分が今 地獄の苦しみを味わってるんですよ
いろんなことに怒って
わかったんで なるほど
これ 1個目で私がこれが分かったら
ニコニコとおおらかにいられるのにと
結構見事ですよ あんたは見事に答えた
やっぱり学ばなくちゃいけないんだと
言って出家しちゃったんです
で やがて修行して阿羅漢になりましたからね
はい そういうことで このブッダを念じるということはね
とてもすごいことですよ
お釈迦様が人を調教する場合は
この上のない能力を持っているんです
それからサッターデワマヌッサム
ブッダっていうのは神々と人間
すべての生命の師匠なんです
ブッダって誰ですか？と言えば師匠先生なんです
誰の？すべての生命の
それからブッダをブッダであって
バガは世尊でありと 世尊というのは幸福をもたらすという意味なんです
ブッダにあったら幸福になる
幸福の泉なんです そうやって如来ブッダという人格を念じるんです
これはもう宗教的なものよりも理性的な
この脳を働かせるんですよ
だからお釈迦様はすごい心理学者なんですよ
我々のだらしない心がどうやって逆にするのかということは
ものすごく精密に知っていたんです
だからこれはマインドコントロールでもなんでもないんです
皆様もそれなりに日常生活でやっている
スポーツやってる人々は誰かがモデルにする
尊敬する人は誰ですか？と言えば
大体の若い人々なんかは誰か誰かさん決まってあの人のことを尊敬してるとかね
そうやって自分があの人ってすごいなと思う人間がいると
なんとなく微妙にその人のやり方と同じやり方をやろうとするんですよ
それって成長でしょ 例えば数学のプロの数学者に憧れたら
その若者たちはやっぱり数学を学ぶんですよ
今の若者はね まあロック音楽やらね
ポップ音楽やらね KPOP
でしたっけね まあそういうことをやっている人に憧れちゃって
真似してそれ同じことやってるでしょ
この踊りやら振りやら服装やら
いろんなことを真似するんです
だから憧れると なんとなくその人とどうかしようとするんですね
だから我々のやり方はどうかと思いますけど
あのポップ音楽やってる連中に憧れちゃってもね
苦しみだけなんですけど
ではなくてね それなりのまとめない人を憧れの対象にしておけば
心が成長していくんですね
それでお釈迦様は究極の人格者
ブッダを念じなさいと教えているんです
如来を観たすると欲がよく心を攻撃しない
怒りが攻撃しない 無知が攻撃しない
心はまっすぐになる ブッダのことを念じると
欲が攻撃しないのは 怒りが攻撃しないのは
無知は攻撃しない いつでも自動的に理性になっているんです
便利でしょ？だから欲を怒り無知が攻撃しない場合は集中力でしょ
心が混乱していない えらい便利なやり方なんです
すごい簡単にできるんです
が この九つのもの項目を学んでもらわないと
あのタイ王国の一般の人々はよくブッダを念じる瞑想をしているんですね
ご利益あるんだ ご利益あるんだっていう話ですけどもね
ちょっと情けないんですけど
で みんな阿羅漢 阿羅漢
阿羅漢 阿羅漢とね あるいはブッダをブッダ
ブッダっていうのは あのタイではプットと言うんですね
だからプット プット プットと念じるんですね
自分となるように しかし
その方々は自分となるように念じても大丈夫です
OK です なぜならば 一応意味はわかっているんです
ブッダをと思っただけでも
なんとなくブッダの人格を心に浮かぶんですね
だからみんな結構効き目があります
だから日本の方々はブッダをブッダと言ったってもね
あまり意味がないんですから
やっぱりまず学んでみて
言葉を作って念じてみると
見るか見る見るうちに心が綺麗になってしまう
はい それで成長の流れがあるんです
流れを覚えてください
心がまっすぐになる まっすぐに働く時
いわゆる揺らぎない 曖昧ない
しっかり芯の強い人間になっちゃいます
至って簡単です ブッダを念じるだけ
ブッダの能力を念じるだけ
ブッダって人格者ではなくてね
このなんでブッダと言うんですかね
ある人間が ある人間がブッダだよということは
その人間には誰にもない能力があったんだからね
その能力はなんなのかと念じるんです
で 心は曖昧なくまっすぐに働き心になる
それで物事のありさま
法則を理解するんです
まっすぐ物事を見えるようになったら
曖昧なく物事を見えるようになったら
ああ こうなっている こうなっている
こうなってくると 物事のありさまが見えてくるんです
法則見えてくるんです
それは真理を理解することですね
あ こうだからこうなった
こうだからこうなったと
冷静には真理を見えてくると楽しいんですよ
なんか勉強すると楽しいでしょ？勉強すると楽しくないんだけど
勉強するものわかってくると楽しいでしょ
わかると楽しいんです
数学の問題でも解きで解いてみると
どんどんうまくいって答えが出てくるとまあ楽しいこと
これも脳の働きなんですよ
問題があって 問題が解けるようになると
脳がなんか興奮するんですよ
みんなそうなんです このパズルゲームでもやってみて
パズルのパズルを解き解いて解いていくと楽しくなっちゃいますね
あ できたとかね これはどんな人間にあることで
お釈迦様がそこで自動的に法則をわかってくると喜びが生まれます
これは並の喜びじゃないんですよ
世の中の物事のありさまをわかっているんだから
ちょっとちっぽけなパズルじゃないんです
数学の問題じゃないんです
生命に対する法則がわかってくると
ものすごい なんて言いますか
楽しみがね ワクワク感が心
脳の中でまーちゃーまちゃ生まれてくる
これって幸せでしょ？いつでも脳が軽くてワクワクして元気いっぱいでいることはね
それで喜びから喜びを感じると体が柔軟になる
これを教案というんですね
この心がすごく喜びを感じて満足していくと
肉体も心もすごい柔軟になるんです
この柔軟であることは必要なんです
この硬いものは壊れるんです
皆様はいろんなことを勉強する上で
生きている上でどんどん頑固になるんです
例えば子供はなんでも
勉強するんだけど 大人になってくると狭くなるでしょ
あれは嫌 これは嫌とかね
自分だけの狭い世界に閉じ込められてしまいます
どんどん頑固になる 体もかなり硬くなる
心も硬くなる 硬くなると成長なしなんです
ですから この種にしたっても
柔らかい種はすぐ芽が出るんですよ
時々ありますよ 私も知ってる
何とかの植物の種がありまして
この種を植えて水をあげて
1年  2年ぐらい経ったらやっと芽が出ます
できますかね  1年  2年面倒を見ると
ただ植えただけね でっかい茎ですけどね
これも私もらったことありましてね
これ植えてみなさい 立派な木になりますよ
しかしですね  2年かかりますよ
芽が出るまで あまりにも頑固な種でしょ
考えてください ホウレンソウの種もそうだったらどうしますかね
トマトの種も 1年かかると言ったら困ったもんでしょ
でもホウレンソウみたいな今日撒いたら次の日なんとか出ているし
トマトもそうでしょうし
1日で2日でもう芽が出ているんですね
やっぱりこの柔らかさは成長なんですね
うん だから心は柔軟ということは
学べる状態になっているんです
成長する状態が出来上がったんです
これで肉体的にも この柔軟でいることっていうのは結構便利なんですよ
そこで体も心も柔軟になったら楽ですね
もう生きる苦しみが消えちゃったんですよ
楽 誰かがややこしいことを言ったっても
もう怒り攻撃しないでしょ
それで楽なんですね ああ
そうですかねと でもわかってます
こうだからこうだからこうなってるんだ
それで楽になるんです
楽になったら楽っていうのは並の楽じゃないんです
これは仏教の世界だから
喜悦感なんです もう脳がこのサクッと喜悦を作る物質をバンバン出しっぱなしになっちゃうんです
それで体の状況もものすごく良くなるんです
ものすごく出てくるんですよ
もう想像できないほど
喜悦感 幸福を経験すると
心が統一になる サマーディが起こる
それでサマーディ状態が生まれてくるんです
あの 4番目 サマーディがもう出ているんです
マハーナーマよ これは
ヴィサマガターパジャヤサマッパットヴィーハル
乱れた人間の中で乱れない生き方と言うんだよ
世の中は乱れて混乱して
原子爆弾作るわ ミサイル発射するわ
もうきりがない ちっぽけな石がかけらに戦争するわ
日本も同じでしょうし
フィリピンも今問題起きているでしょうに
うん 本当にすごい怖い世界でしょ
あれは横でしょ フィリピンにしたっても
ちょっとした 石とかみたいなおところなんで
これはフィリピンの中国
俺のもの 日本で言えば何島でしたっけ？石垣島
尖閣諸島  なんとかですね
それで台湾もクレームつけるし
中国もクレームつけるし
で いいんですかって そっちもなんかクレームつけてるみたいし
まあどうでもいいことですけどね
そんなの潰しちゃえば簡単ですけどね
だからちょっとしたもう人は立てないぐらい小さな石なんですけど
これ日本はどれほど苦しんでいるのかいと
だからそういうふうに世の中を見ると
みんな混乱だらけで 自己破壊で殺されるようにわざと生きているんです
この世の中で落ち着いていられます
この流れで だから頑張ってみなさいと
マハーナーマ それから瞋恚に侵されている人々の中で
怒りのない慈しみの生き方である
みんな瞋恚で苦しんで自己破壊している間で穏やかにやれます
放矢 瞋恚の流れに入ることを目指して如来を念じるのです
ですから 念仏しなさいと
しかし この宗教の念仏じゃないんです
これは智慧を開発する目的で
神秘体験するためのじゃないんです
南無阿弥陀仏と唱えることで
阿弥陀仏が見えて見えてほしいやとかね
そういうふうに精神的にちょっとおかしい状況を作るんじゃなくて
理性を持って念仏をする
念仏すると あの宗教っていうのはだいたい何か神秘体験欲しがるんですよ
あるんですけど ちょっと何か違うことをやると
いろいろ経験は起こりますけど
阿弥陀様を見たい人はいるんですよ
念仏を唱える だからそれがいいのか
それで人格向上したのかと
貪瞋痴がなくなったのかと
ということが問題なんです
あなた 脳の次元を破ったのかよ
それはちゃんとした仮性民主的な科学でやらなくちゃいけないことなんです
そういうことで 智慧に基づいて念仏をしなさいと
あなたはこれぐらいのことを獲得しますよと
この実践すれば解脱の流れに入ってしまうのだという意味になります
ですから 解脱を目指す
目指したいんだけど 在家だから
面倒くさい だったら念仏ぐらい唱えれば
まあ仏念ですね ぐらいすればどうですか？簡単でしょうに
やればうまくきますよ
はい 次 法然増念ということですね
法について観察するのです
念じることです はい これは個人差があります
あります ある個人には
イティピソダーラハンというブッダの特色を唱えられます
念じられますし ある人はやっぱりブッダは置いておいて
法に気が行くんですね
スワカーとこの文章あります
皆さんは覚えています
スワカーとバガタダンム
ブッダの教えは完璧にと説かれています
いわゆる矛盾ない 疑問ない
完璧になると説かれています
だから 教えを読みながら
どこか完璧かい これは
とかね 何かケチつけるところはありますか？とかね
調べてみてください 何かケチをつけるところはありますか？とかね
見つかりませんよ  2600年も経ってますけど
いまだにブッダのところで説かれた言葉には矛盾がないのです
完璧なんです それは私もびっくりするんですよ
もう どうやってこのように完璧に語れるのかと
私も喋る人間だから やっぱり興味あるんですよ
みんないろいろ批判言ったり
文句言ったり 不機嫌になったりするのは
私の言葉は不完全だからでしょ
断言的で一方的で 時々かなり侮辱的な言葉も言ったり
いろんなことをやっていますから
これで皆もう説法を聞いて気持ちよくなったんじゃなくて
最悪気持ち悪くなったから腹が立ってしまったという状態にもなります
それをなんとか直せるのかと私も考えているんだけど
やっぱりその能力がないんですね
いわゆるお釈迦様にあるのはあるわけないでしょ
お釈迦様にある能力はないんで
これはブッダだけに限った能力なんだ
完璧に解く サンディッティコ
いつだって有効です いわゆる目の前で見なさいと言えるんです
アカーリコ 時間とは関係ない
時間経ても経ても ブッダの教えは教えです
真理は真理です エイパシコ
見なさい 調べなさいと言えるオープンな教えです
これ結構やばいんですよ
はい 誰でも世の中の人々
この教えを調べてください
すべてオープンですよ
こうやって世間に放り投げることは仏教だけですよ
コーランなんかはうっかり落としたら大変ですよ
すごい怖いんです 落とすんです
そうやってこの閉鎖的にするんですね
私は昔 若い頃ね カトリック教のね
いわゆる神父様たちも仲良くしてもらったからね
あの 言ったら 私はプロテスタントの聖書を持って読んでみようと思ったけど
カトリック教のバージョンの聖書は一つも手に入らないんですから
なんとか手に入る方法ないんですか？だからカトリック教もちょっと勉強していていたんですね
じゃあ勉強はしているんですけど
いろいろくだらないことばっかしで
聖書から一部一部引用して
そこは解説したりとか
面白くないな 善人の話とか
私は聖書そのものを読みたいね
言ったら聖書は読んではいけませんよ
それはプロだけ読むものですと
何でしょうかと聞いたら
やっぱり理解できなくて頭がおかしくなります
あ そうですかね それで諦めちゃったんですけど
いたって簡単に聖書は手に入るし
まあ別にカトリック教のバージョンとプロテスタントバージョンはそんな差がないし
それから見たら 聖書を読む人がどうせ頭イカれますよ
なぜかというと これはもう後であの
書いたもんでしょ 本人じゃないんですね
一つ  そういうことはどうでもいいんですが
仏教の場合はね 来たれ見よというのはすごいことなんですよ
だから そういうふうに法のありがたさ
法の素晴らしさを念じてください
それも気に入らない場合はそう念しなさいと
その場合はまた文章があります
スパティパンのバゴと
坊主だからそう念じゃないんで
私のことだけは忘れた方が身の安全なんです
だからこのスパティパンのバゴとサーガサンゴという阿羅漢たちのこと
聖者たちのこと だから今は馴染みがないんだからね
どうしようもないんだけど
昔はね 一般人が誰かの阿羅漢の式のことを知っていて
個人的にそうすると心が惹かれるんですね
だからその坊さんのこと
性格のことを念じてみる
だから その場合も特色を念じるんですね
スパティパンのウジュパティパンのサーミチパティパンのナーヤパティパンの
というふうに 成長の流れは上と同じです
まず怒りが攻撃しない
欲が攻撃しない 無知が攻撃しない
心は落ち着いてくる 喜び
物事を見えてくる 世の中の喜びが生まれてくるという流れは同じなんです
3番目 はい 4番目に入ります
あと2つ残っています
4番目はアッタノシーラーニャノスリヤス
自分が犯す 犯すことなく守っている道徳
戒ですね を念じるのです
汚点なく 隙間なく 戒律を守っていることを念じてみるのです
はい 仏年法年僧年はできないと
やりたくないというならば
自分自身の戒を念じてください
マハーナーマサンだから五戒守っている
またシャカ族だからプライドはめちゃめちゃ高い民族だから
真面目に守る 人に言われるのは大嫌いなんです
何か言われる だから絶対誰にも何も言われないように
自分の人格を守っていたんです
だからマハーナーマサンに言うんです
あなたのあなたが守っている戒律を念じたらどうですか？だから五戒なくても
例えば自分がこの戒律を守りますと決めたら
これは完璧に守ってみるんです
プライドを持って戒律を守るんです
どんな障害があっても貫くんです
殺生しないと決まったところで
友達が釣りに行こうよ
せっかくのゴールデンウィークだからとかね
車もありますよ ホテルも予約してやりますよと
これ 1年前予約しましたよ
あれやこれやというと行きたくなるでしょ
だからそういうふうにいろいろ誘惑があっても
私は殺生しないよ そういうふうに一項の戒律でも貫くんですね
隙間ないように守ってくる
それで自分が捨てたもんじゃないよと
しっかり戒律を守っているんだと念じてみる
私は嘘をつきませんと
これは人に言うんじゃないんです
人に言うんじゃなくて
私は嘘をつかない ついたことがない
この戒律を守ってまあ
5年も経っている それから破ったことはない
怪しいところはないと
と思っちゃうと なんとなく自信がついてくるでしょう
そう思っちゃうと 怒り
貪瞋痴が攻撃しないでしょう
心が集中するんです 喜びが生まれていきます
これでも脳の開発が起こるのです
はい  5番目に行きましょう
これはチャリティですね
あのチャリティっていうのはパーリ語はチャーガなんです
もしかすると語感が似ている可能性あります
チャーガ これは不正とかあまりよくない
かっこ悪い あの単語は寄付という単語を使おうかなと思ったんです
なんかかっこ悪いんですね
私が思うチャリティじゃないんですね
チャーガではないんです
だからチャリティという単語を使っちゃったんです
チャーガは英訳するとチャリティですから
まあ日本語でもチャリティで使ってるしね
あったの チャーガなんですよ
言いやすい 自分の不正
寄付行為を観察するんです
これで自分の性格を観察するんですね
私はチャリティ精神ですと
物惜しみしません ケチではありません
自分が得たものはみんなで
あ どうぞどうぞ あなたも一緒にどう？という感じで
オープンハンドという
あのパエタパーに手を
はい どうぞ そういう性格です
それから他人には頼み事をしやすい人間であること
人とはね 知り合いとか知り合いでないとでも
何か困ったことがあったら
何も躊躇もなく私に頼むんだよ
助けてください ちょっと困ってますよと
それで私はそれを何とかしてあげよう
だからチャリティーというのは金あげるだけじゃないんですよ
このチャリティ精神 いろんなものをあげるんだからね
今更できませんだけど
例えば長旅した人がもう夜泊まるところがなくて
それであの人は結構チャリティー精神やとわかったら何か
なことなる 本当に困りましたけどね
宿は取れないんだ あ そう
じゃあいいよ いいよ いい
泊めてください 泊めてください
いう風な感じ だから自分がそういうチャリティー精神を持ってるんだから
それを念じてみなさい
はい ここでこのからくりがありまして
良いことをするだけじゃないんです
良いことをして 脳にそれは再確認させるんです
あなたはこういうような人間だよ
ですから 動物的な精神で生きているでしょ？原始脳で生きているでしょ
この再確認することで原始脳が機能停止するんです
して人格者になるんです
これが微妙なところなんですね
他宗教でも人を助けなさいとかね
すごく言うんだけど この脳科学的に脳にフィードバックすることがあるかどうかよくわからないんです
ここでお釈迦様が言うのは
これは脳にフィードバックさせてあげてください
あげて原始脳の機能を停止してほしいんですね
心は前と同じく成長していくのです
はい  6番目 神々を念じる
デーヴァタアヌッセレヤ
神々のことを念じてみるんです
なんで仏教は神を念じるように言ってるんですかね
これは仏教の神々なんですね
あの宗教の神を念じることじゃない
宗教の神だったら念じるんじゃなくて祈るでしょ
神を讃嘆したり祈ったりするんですね
祈ることと讃嘆することでどうなるかというと
仏教は大反対なんですね
自分が惨めになるんです
全知全能の神様よと呼んだ時点で
私は何者でもありませんという意味なんです
聖書の真ん中にこのサームスというセクションがありますね
歌なんですね 歌としては悪くないんだけど
あれは読むのは惨めになること
だって偉大なる神を讃嘆する賛美歌ばっかりで
みんなかっこいい言葉やと思って書いてますけど
私はこれはダメや これで惨めになるだけでね
私の意見ではなく 汝神の意見を通してくださいと
まあ解釈によりますけど
私の自我中心的な意見ではなく
神の意見でよろしいと言えば構わないんだけど
神も自我中心だからね
結局 だからそういうふうなことで脳は成長しません
仏教の神々を念じる方法を覚えておきましょう
仏教では六天があるんだと
天界六つありますね これからその上
梵天もたくさんあります
たくさんあります その梵天の上もまた天があります
どの程度の信サッダーがあって
神々はこの ここで亡くなって天に生まれたのでしょうか
私にもそれぐらいの信があります
そういうふうに念じるんです
これが本当は昔は簡単で
昔は仏教の場合はこの神々と馴染みが深かったんです
帝釈天やらいろんな神々は
まあそっち仏教の信者さんに会ったり話したりする
ある日 アーナンダ尊者がね
在家の人々の仕事でもう何日もクタクタ疲れちゃって
だって在家の方々 お釈迦様に会いたいと言ったら
アーナンダ尊者が管理しなくちゃあかんだからね
状況を聞いて どういうことですか？とかね
あなたはまあ危ない あなたはちょっと待ってくださいとか
あなたはすぐお釈迦様になってくださいとかね
それ管理するんですよ
それで在家の人々はだからいつでもアーナンダ尊者といろんな悩み事やらいろんな問題言うんです
アーナンダ尊者 お釈迦様をお教えしなくちゃいけないし
その上もう在家の人々の受け付けをしなくちゃいけないんですね
修行する暇はまるっきりゼロない
それでクタクタ疲れて歩ききっているんですね
である神が来て アーナンダ尊者を叱るんですね
あんたね アーナンダ尊者
この在家の俗世間のことにね
一日中むちゃくちゃ構っていて
これはダメでしょ 心を清らかにするように頑張らなくちゃあかんでしょ
そう言って帰るんですね
だから心配するんですよ
それじゃあそれはそうですねとかね
そういうことで 馴染みがあるんですね
神々と この我々みたいな
えたい知らないということではなくてね
当時ではね よくコミュニケーションは取っていたみたい
だから当時ではこれは簡単にできましたし
今やるならば 仏典にあるエピソードを参考にしなくてはいけないんですね
例えば帝釈天を念じる場合は
帝釈天はどんな修行をして帝釈天になったのかと記録してあるんですよ
それで あ これぐらいのことを俺もやってるんだよと思ってください
だから念じ方違うんですね
例えば帝釈天が天の神になったのは
第一ボランティアなんですね
ものすごい福祉業に頑張ったんです
それから親孝行はものすごい厳しいんです
それから目上の人はものすごく尊敬するんです
年寄りなんかは一生懸命尊敬する
それは謙虚なんです それがいい
だったら今もね もう何て言いますか
ボランティアやったり
福祉と福祉に手を焼いている方々はね
朝から晩までなんかボランティアや福祉活動をやっている方々も
帝釈天ってどんな神かいと
まあ福祉活動をやったと
そういえば私も 一生もう一日中福祉活動にもそれやってますよ
同じこっちゃよ そう思ってほしいんです
帝釈天がね 家が潰れた人に家を作ってあげたとか
昔はそんな簡単でしたけどね
今現代では難しいんだけど
我々やっていますよ 年寄りやら寝たきりの方々とかね
面倒見てあげて 昔もやってましたけど
昔より今は大変ですけど
やってますよ ちゃんと精一杯というふうに考えてほしいんです
同じフレーズを戒律と知識
チャーガ パンニャーにも注意ということは
あの神がどれぐらいの戒律を守って
その結果天界に生まれたのでしょうかと
その神が守った程度の戒律は私も守っていますよ
あの神はどれぐらい仏教を学んで
どれぐらい知識があって
知識のおかげで天界に生まれ変わったでしょうか
そんな程度の知識は私にもあります
あの神がどれぐらいのチャリティーを行って県に生まれたんですか？こんな程度のチャリティーなら私もやってますよというふうに調子に乗ることなんです
惨めになることじゃないんです
神は偉いと 人間よりはるかに力があるんだと
これが仏教の神を念じる瞑想じゃないんです
仏教の神を念じる瞑想は調子に乗るだけなんです
うん 私にもそれぐらいの道徳はありますよ
対等で見るんです 神を
こんにちはっていう気分で見るんです
よく覚えてください 神々は友達であって対等なんです
だから何か困ったことがあったらね
もし仏教の神々の名前を知っているならばね
まあその名前でね ちょっと困ってますからね
ちょっと助けてちょうだい
まあ言ったら仏教とかそうやるんですよ
それで他の方々はね あの
この人と仏教と言いながら神を信仰するでしょ
迷信ばっかりでしょ は言われますけど
まあ外から見れば迷信なんですけど
仏教の中から見れば どうって友達も頼んで何が悪いんですよ
あいつらの力があるんだからという態度なんです
それぐらいのこと頼んだっていいや
ということで頼むことはするんです
そういうことで友達に見るんですね
対等で見るんですね 神々を対等で見て
このサッダシーラ スッタ
チャーガ パンニャーというものでチェックするんです
そこで覚えてください
天国に生まれ変わりたければ
サッダ シーラ スッタ チャーガ
パンニャ これの 5つの一つ守らなくちゃ
例えばチャリティーを行う人々も
このチャリティー精神になって死ぬ場合は
天界に直接生まれるのです
いたって簡単です たまにチャリティーをやって嫌になってやめたはダメです
もうこりごりよ やりませんとだダメなんです
やっぱり人格的にチャリティー精神にならなくちゃいけない
毎日チャリティーできるわけないかもしれませんだけど
チャンスがあったらやりますよ
チャリティーをしたいんだ
ボランティアしたいんだ
体を張って人のために頑張りたいんだ
そういう性格が必要です
ただの行為だけじゃないんです
私は 100万円をチャリティーに寄付しました
はい さようなら  8万円あげたでしょうにって調子に乗っちゃうと徳にはならないんですね
まあ自分の力いっぱい 100万円までましたけど
まあやっぱりチャリティーはいいですねとかね
できればね まあその精神で生きていたいなとか
そういうふうに人格に入れてください
すぐ目が閉じた目が開けるような感じで天国に生まれます
いたって簡単です 天界に生まれることは
それから貝の帰る人の場合もありで
まあ天国に行くのはすごい簡単です
5つですね それで心が成長するんです
解脱に思うんです 神々を念じると
この何といいますか サッダサティ
サッダ シーラ スッタ チャーガ
パンニャ  5つですね サッダ
シーラ スッタ チャーガ
パンニャ この 5つを念じてるんですね
神々のサッダ 神々のシーラ
神々のスッタ 神々のチャーガ
神々のパンニャ それは念じています
例えばヒンドゥー教の神々だったら怖い神々もいるでしょ
仏教は扱いません カーリーとかね
怖い女神ですよ で イーシュワラ神とかね
怖いんですね そういうのはなくて
仏教は仏教独特の神々の世界を作ってあるんです
みんなすごい道徳を守る人々で
お坊さんたちにも叱ったりする人々で
こういうことで天界のこういうことを念じると
心に心が 欲の攻撃を受けません
怒りの攻撃を受けません
無知の攻撃を受けません
物事は見えてくる そうすると楽しくなってくる
楽しくなってくると心が集中する
すごい清さが生まれてくる
集中する 集中したところで真理を見えてきて
解脱への達する はい これで話は終わりとなります
究極の幸福は出家に限ったものではありません
在家も道徳的で さらに様々な義務を果たして理性を保って生きるならば
この経典に説かれた方法で解脱を目指して生活することは可能ですということですね
はい これでお釈迦様のプレゼントはそれなので
皆様は皆様の毎日の仕事をして
義務を果たして生活してください
だからで皆様に解脱の扉を開けてます
で このやり方を頑張ってみてください
という 11 の項目をお釈迦様が在家の方々にプレゼントとして与えているんです
それはすごいプレゼントでしょ
やってみれば まあ幸せにはなります
それで今日の話は終了いたします
はい どうもありがとうございます
[拍手] よろしくお願いします
えーと これからあの ウェーサーカの法要を法話会を始まりたいと思います
で あの 普段いろいろ面白いことを喋りますけどね
今回は 期待に沿えなくて超つまらない内容になるとは思います
頑張らないと もうどうなることかよくわからないんです
内容は難しくはないんですけどね
スライドをお願いします
あのウェーサックというのは
仏教徒に対してのお正月ですので
あの正月の祝福もしたいと思います
で 仏年号はね 最初に会長の挨拶にありましたように
ブディストという仏教仏歴ですね
2557年になりました
25日からなんですけどね
世界的に大体その年数で仏教の仏歴を数えています
それはお釈迦様が涅槃に入られてから
一年は一に数えているんですね
お誕生からではないんです
ですから お釈迦様がそれに 80年足すと
お釈迦様はいつ生まれたのかということがわかります
それで 今日はお釈迦様の教えの基本はね
皆様 仏教の話をいっぱい聞いていらっしゃいますから
まあ基本的なところをまとめましょうかなというふうに思ったんですね
で 基本的なところだけではなくて
この基本的にブッダの教えはいろいろ特色あるんですね
で そこはちょっとハイライトした方が
私たちにとってはしっかりすると思います
でないと いつでも心は曖昧で
あれ あちらもこう言ってる
こちらもこう言ってる
あちらもこう言ってるとかね
頭がなかなかね あの まあ揺らいじゃいますね
優柔不断状態になっちゃうんですね
釈迦牟尼仏陀の教えの特色はこれこれやとはっきりした方が
まあ各自でどんな宗派にするのか
どんな宗教にするのかという判断ができると思います
お釈迦様はこの基本的に言えば
この信仰の代わりに確信というものなんで
一番大事なのは 宗教とは信仰なんですね
どんな宗教でも何か信じるものを持ってくるんですね
この信じる対象っていうのはすごく私
私たち個人よりはすごい偉大なるもので
まあそれを信じましょうと
だから絶対的偉大なる何かあるかどうか誰もわからないんですね
正直なところは ただ あればいいなというね
我々の希望だけはありますね
これ 仏教から見ると そんなすごい絶対的存在があるならば
こんなアリ一匹にも足らない自分の命のことは全くへっちゃら
気にもしないだろうと思いますけどね
しかし 私たちは宗教の世界では私のことをとても可愛がってくれるだろうと
私のことを特別にすごい預かってくれるだろうといって
必死になって信仰したり祈ったりはする
それはあの 人間がまあ宗教を作ったその時点からもあった感情なんですね
何か自分より偉い 絶対たる力に依存する
怯える 敬意を払うという環境感情はね
これはなぜですかというと
やっぱり我々弱いんですよ
いくらなんでも 特にね
原始時代のことを考えると
獲物を取ろうと言ったって
自分が獲物になってしまうことっていうのはもうゴブゴブなんですね
だから病気になったら
ただ風邪ひいちゃってもね
今は大丈夫ですけど 昔は風邪ひいたってそれで死んじゃう可能性もありましたしね
だから自分の力のなささというか
力の弱さっていうのは
我々は遺伝子持って知ってるんですね
生命 地球上の生命はみんなを知ってます
人間になって 地球に生命
人間が現れて それほど時間経ってないんだけど
生命はものすごく長い間いるんだからね
だからあなたは鳥に足らない弱いものであるという記録は
私たちの遺伝子にはあるんですね
だから助けてくれっていうのは
私たちにとってはごく普通のことなんですね
で 問題は助けてくれと助けてもらっているという気持ちになっても
人間が弱いのはそのままなんですね
だからお釈迦様の特色は
この助けてくれということは削除するんですね
これは大胆なことなんですね
人間が弱いということを知ってますけど
だから何をと強くなればいいんじゃないかと
それでどこで強くなれるのかというと
肉体では強くなれませんね
ですから お釈迦様は智慧というものを提案するんですね
ですから この私たちにとって
この宗教と仏教の違うところを言いますけど
この一番大事なところは
お釈迦様がおっしゃっている
この今日のテーマの 1ですね
生きることは苦でありますという
これが誰も認めていないものなんですね
世の中で生きることは幸福だろうと
生きていきたいだろうという前提で生きているんですね
だからうまくいかないと誰かに助けてくれと言うんですね
だから生きていきたいんですね
お釈迦様は生きるとは何かと徹底研究して
生きるとは苦でありますと発見しますね
じゃあ次に行きます それで 2番目のポイントは
この自分自身が作った鎖で
いわゆる煩悩ですね 束縛されて自由はない
で それ仏教は特別に説かれるもので
他の宗教ではいろいろ言ってますけど
各宗教によって教えが違いますけど
あの 私たちはお釈迦様から見れば
生命は人間だけじゃなくて
自分で掘った穴に落ちてるんですね
穴を掘っているのは 神でも悪魔でも誰でも他人でもなくて
自分で穴を掘ってるんですね
落とし穴をね 自分で落とし穴を掘って自分で飛び込むんですね
それから苦しいと泣くんですね
助けてくれと だから助けてあげられないでしょうね
あげたくないでしょうね
自分で落とし穴を掘って
それに勝手に落ちたならばね
勝手にしろよと言いたくなるんですね
それでこの これは冗談みたいに言ったんですけど
この心理は深いんですね
我々の心で この煩悩という鎖が出てきて現れてきて
自分をもうずっと束縛されています
はい 次の で 幸福を目指して不幸の方向へ歩むと
次の人間の問題は 生命
人間誰でも幸福になりたいんだけど
やってることでは幸福になるどころか不幸になるがすぎる
で 他に頼って助けられること
救われることを望む ですから
自分で頑張っても不幸になるんだから
まあ依存することに決めちゃうんですね
で  5番目は自分が作った束縛を足すことで自由を得る
それで答え簡単ですね
自分で落とし穴掘らなきゃいいでしょうし
掘ったとしたっても 自分が掘った穴だから
もうそれから立ち上がればいいでしょうに
ですから 心にあるこの束縛は自分が作ったものなんです
これだったら自分で破りなさいと
自分が鍵をかけたならば
自分で開けなさいと だから自分で手錠をかけたならば
本人が鍵も持ってるでしょうに
だったら泣くんじゃなくて
自分で開けなさいよっていうのは仏教
お釈迦様の教えのやり方なんですね
6番目は 智慧こそが唯一の財産
はい そのやり方は智慧というんですね
足に手に もう生命全体に我々は手錠をかけられちゃって
身動きできなくて苦しんでますね
これで あれ これ私がやっちゃったんだと
誰かに手錠をかけられたわけじゃないんだと
だから手錠を持ってるということは
鍵を持ってるということなんですね
じゃあこれは私で開けなくちゃいけないということで
まあ自分でこれ この発見することが智慧なんですね
はい 次  7番目に探したいのは
智慧によって執着をなくすことによって究極の幸福に達する
それで次の問題 我々は生きていきたい
生きていきたいというこのすごい執着
存在欲があるんですね
これは生きることは苦であるとわかっていないだからなんですね
だから本当のところは頑張って生きてみようではなくて
執着捨てることなんです
まあいいんじゃないかと
別にという感じで この生きることに対する執着を捨てることが解脱の道なんですね
そうするとすごく楽になるんです
世の中の物事 我々にはね
自分勝手に変化できませんでしょ
変化させたいんで 子供は自分の希望通りに成長してほしいし
世界は自分の希望通りに動いてほしいし
商売をやる人は 世界の経済状況が自分が儲けるように回ってほしいしね
もうこんなことはね ありえないでしょうに
しかし 欲しいんだから苦しいんですよ
自分の会社で作る品物はヒットしてほしいし
ヒットしない場合は苦しくなっちゃうんですね
だからそちらに苦しみが作っているのは束縛なんですね
ですから 束縛を捨てるたびに楽になるんです
自分の家にあるゴミとかいろいろね
処分すればするほど気持ちいいでしょう
だからいろんなもの 思い出のものとか
あれやこれやとか 段ボール箱に入れてね
もうテープを貼って置いちゃうと
結構もう束縛なんですね
火事になったらどうしようかとかね
火事になったら持ち逃げるものっていうのは
あまりにも大量でトラック2台ぐらい必要になっちゃうんですね
だから何もない人が 家が火事になったらそのまま逃げればいいでしょ
その人は何も損していないんだというね
感じになるんですね いっぱいものを持ってる人だったら
家が火事になったらどん底さ
てるんですね だって何を持ち逃げできま...持って逃げられませんだからね
はい で  8番目の項目で
究極の幸福は今この世で体験するもの
これも大事なポイントなんですね
お釈迦様が説かれたとても大事なポイントなんですね
これは世の中で誰も言ってないんですね
今ここで涅槃を経験しなさいと
すごい科学者なんですよ
明日ダメですよって教えなんですね
で はい それから一つ一つ一つずつ説明していきます
では 生きることは苦でありますということで
生きることは最高だと皆勘違いしている
私たちは生きることって最高だと勘違いしていますよ
私の話を聞いている方々は
別な意見もついでに持っているかもしれませんだけど
そうではなくて 正直になりましょう
正直に素直になって考えたら
やっぱり生きるって最高やという気持ちであるはずなんです
で これ勘違いなんですね
なぜ勘違いだといきなり決めるなよと
実験して あるいは研究してみましょうよと
光っただけで金じゃないでしょ
光るものは金だとするためには
やっぱり検査しなくちゃあかんでしょう
胸が痛くなっただけで心臓発作じゃないでしょ
調子が悪くなっただけで
がんにかかってるわけじゃないでしょう
だから そういうふうないい加減なことをしないで調べなくちゃあかんですね
胸が痛いんだったら ちゃんとお医者さんを頼んで検査してもらうんですね
もらったら お医者様があなたの胸の痛みはこういうことであると調べて言うんだから
そこを認めればいいでしょう
だから 生きるって最高という風にいきなり決めるのはちょっとおかしいというのが仏教的立場なんですね
生きることは苦を避ける
なくす終わりのない戦いなんです
それで研究してみると
生きるという働きがあるんですよ
一番わかりやすい働きは呼吸しているんですね
生きるために呼吸を止めたら死んじゃうんですね
じゃあそれ調べましょう
一旦呼吸を止めてみる
面倒くさいやと これはね
お腹の中でも一応呼吸してましたし
生まれてから空気を呼吸しているしね
面倒くさいんだからね
じゃあまあ 20 分ぐらい呼吸を止めたらどうですかね
20 分短すぎですかね
じゃあまあ ただ 1 分 2 分呼吸を止めてみたら
激痛に襲われますよ それで死を思う
死を意味するんですね
死んじゃいますよ だから体に
肉体に激痛があって 吸ったり吐いたり
吸ったり吐いたりすることで
この苦しみをごまかしても逃げています
例えば吐き出して止めたら苦しくてたまらない
それで吸う 吸ったら吐いた苦しみが消えた
しかし 吸った苦しみが現れた
それから吸ったままでいる
いるとまた同じ激痛が生まれてくる
もう死にかけちゃう 危ない
それで吐く それで吸った苦しみが消えたんだけど
吐いた苦しみが生じたんです
この連続なんですね どこが最高ですかね
吸っても苦しいし 吐いても苦しいんですよ
だから我々は罠にはめられてるんですね
やめられないんですね
それからご飯食べるでしょ
あれ 苦しいんだからなんですよ
ご飯食べなかったら なんで体を動かしたりしているんですかね
体動かさなかったら 大変な苦しみが生まれてくるんですよ
なんで本を読んだり 映画を見たり
音楽を聴いたりしているんですかね
退屈でしょうがないんですよ
何もやらないでじっとしていると
もう極端に苦しくなってくるんです
だから生きるということはね
仕事をするは 呼吸するは
ご飯食べるは 運動するは
スポーツセンターにも行くわ
友達とも喋るは 映画館にも行く
音楽を聴くとかね 友達関係
人間関係を築くは 結婚式もやるは
葬式もやるわとかね いろんなことをやっているでしょうね
あれ すべて調べてみると
何かしらの苦しみをなんとかごまかしているんです
だから一つの苦を乗り越えると新たな苦が起こるんです
どうしようもないんです
これが生きることです
現実的である苦を 妄想で
夢を見ることで 将来に期待することで
迷信で 盲信で 他に頼ることで
絶対的な存在に必ず 必ず 2つ入ってますけど
一つ除け 助けてくれるなどの信仰で
また優越論にしがみついて誤魔化している
これが我々の生き方なんですね
現実的に苦しみになるんですよ
これ見たくないんです
まあ例えばね 患者さんの体を切ったり貼ったりするときは
医者が患者さんには見せませんね
怖がりますからね 自分の体を開けたままで
はい 見てくださいと言ったらね
相当怖がるでしょうね
見たくないんですね だから私たちは朝から晩まで頑張ってますけど
どうも苦しみだけ消えてないんですね
苦しみは種類がありましてね
ABCD とかね 例えば吐く苦しみ
吸う苦しみ これ 2種類でしょ
これずっと A から B  B から A から BA から B と
そこだけやってるんですね
それで空腹の苦しみと満腹の苦しみ
ご飯を食べると その間で行ったり来たり
行ったり来たり 美味しいご飯を食べられるでしょうと
それ楽しいでしょうかね
本当は この味は皆様に研究できないんだけど
味っていうのは楽しみじゃないんですよ
苦しみなんですね 私は最近もうもう 10ヶ月間ぐらいかけてますけど
味のない食べ物を食べようという実験をしているんです
塩は全く使わない それでたまたま外で食べたり
ちょこちょこちょこやってると
もう塩が入ったものがありますね
私 なんか殴られたような感じで
すごいぐっすりになっちゃうんです
もう涙が来るんですね
もう耐えられなくて でも皆様は塩がなければ食えないという感じでしょ
まずいと じゃあ想像してください
塩をかけてない あの魚の焼きとかね
食べられないと思いますよ
で で 私は何を実験しているのかというと
本当にこの魚の塩焼きがおいしいですか？とかね
本当にこの味噌汁がおいしいでしょうか？という実験なんです
味噌汁は作りません 初めから味噌入ってるんだから
そこで大豆を茹でて食べても
ただ水を入れて茹でてそのまま食べてみるんですね
皆様ならこれまずいでしょうと
なんとか入れなくちゃってことになっちゃうんです
だから普通には味が楽しみだと思ってますけど
じゃあ味なし 生きてみて
たまに味が入っちゃうと
ああ これって美味しいってことにならないんです
びっくりするんですね
よくもこんなきついことを食べていたなとかね
はい そういうことで 味さえも
よく調べるとそんなに楽しみじゃないんですね
皆様にできる実験を教えます
例えばあの甘い味がね
人間っていうのは誰でも好きな
それは体に砂糖が必要ですからね
では 病気の方々はね  1食抜かしちゃって
飴を持って 1個舐めて
それ終わったらもう 1個舐めて
それ終わったらもう 1個とかにやってみてください
3個目はいけないと思いますよ
まあお茶飲みながらやっちゃうとね
袋丸ごと食べられますけどね
ではなくて 甘い 何かの飴のその味だけ
やってみると ものすごく気持ち悪くなるんです
舌が麻痺するんです  そういうことで
生きるということは 我々いろいろ楽しいためと思ってますけど
結局は苦しみなんです
それは心が知ってるんですよ
これやりきれない やりきれないと
それで心が興奮するっていうか
混乱する 苛立つ それで心がうまいこと幻覚を作るんです
だから我々は夢見るんでしょ？すごい普通に夢見るのは普通だと
普通です あれは だっていろんな悩み事を抱えてない人間がいないんだから
だから夢見るんですね
夢でも悩み事を叶ってくれるならばありがたいんだけど
これまずいんですね 夢で悩み事を叶う場合もあるし
叶わない場合は一番多いんですね
だから私は若いと子供の頃思ったんですけど
この試験に準備していたんですね
とにかく私はもう頑張って全部満点取るぞと覚悟して頑張っていた時なんですね
で それである日夢見ちゃったんですね
夢見たら試験は始まっているんだけど
私は試験場に行ってないんですね
あ これ大変だという夢の中でえらいびっくりしちゃったんですね
ここまで勉強してたのに
時間に合わせて試験場に行けなかったら
もう 15分経ったらもう試験場に入れてくれないし
あ どうしようかと また同じ夢を見て
もう試験場で質問とかなんとか出てあるんだけど
どうも何書いてるか読めないんですね
あら これ質問票 質問自体読めないとどうやって返事できるのかいと
えらいショックを感じた覚えがあるんですよ
だから夢も助けてくれないね
で 皆様にも時々夢で絶望感を味わって
恐怖感を味わってということもありますよ
とにかく我々は夢を見る
なぜ夢を見るかというと
精神的にすごく苛立ちがあるんだからなんですね
それからいっぱい妄想する
いっぱい妄想する あまりにも妄想する
それから迷信がありますね
あちらに行ったらなんとかご利益
こちらに行ったらなんとかご利益というね
あれも苦しみをなくすごまかしなんですね
どこかに行って何かもらったんだから何かっていうことはないとは思いますけどもね
あのところでお祈りすれば宝くじが当たるなんて言ったらみんな行っちゃえばいいんだけど
そんなことあまりないしね
あのところに行ってお祈りしてもらっちゃえば病気治ります
言ったらね 病院に行かないでそちらに行けばいいんだけど
まあそんな現実的な話はあまりないんでしょ
本当のところは 何にも関わらず行くんですね
キトー氏は結構儲かっちゃうし
こういう信仰系の宗教も結構儲かってますね
みんないくらでもお金出しますね
結果ないと知ってるんだけど
認めたくないんですね
それも我々は苦しんでいるという証拠なんですね
それから妄信するんですね
それから耐える 耐える
耐える あの人 この人とかね
最終的な作った巨大な妄想は
この絶対的存在がいるんだよと
証拠ないんですよ 誰にも
でもそこを妄想で逃げてますね
あの絶対的神とか何とか信仰することで
結構人々は落ち着いてます
結構落ち着いてます で
あるいは現代知識 現代というかね
知識人たちは宗教は嫌いで
唯物論を作るんですね
あの唯物論も科学的じゃないんです
日本もどちらかというと現代人は唯物論傾向なんですね
一部は唯物論傾向 一部は迷信傾向って綺麗に分かれます
で 唯物だけやと物質だけやと思ったら
まあいいや 死んじゃったら全部終わりだからと落ち着くんです
だからそれも一つのごまかしなんですね
毎日 毎時毎分 自分の生き方をそのまま観察すると
自分がただ苦をなくそうと闘っているという現実を発見できます
だから そんな難しい実験じゃないんです
今日一日はどんな人生ですかと見れば
自分がまあ結構頑張ったんだということをね
いろんなトラブルがあって
このトラブルを乗り越えるために頑張ったんですね
あ よかったよかった これから終わりということはないんですね
また明日も同じこと あるいは 1 日は長いんだったら 1 時間以内チェックする
やっぱり 1 時間チェックしても苦しみがあって
それを乗り越えようと頑張っているんですね
まあそれも時間長いと思ったら
まあ毎分 毎秒 をチェックしても
苦しみから逃げる 苦しみから逃げるということは生きることなんですね
だからずっと一貫して我々を襲われているのは苦しみなんです
同時に 生きることに徹底的に執着していることが発見できる
これで毎秒毎秒自分の人生を見ると
執着が見えてくるんですね
例えばお腹がすいた 苦しみでしょ
食べるものにいきなり執着が生まれてくるんですね
あれ食べたい これ食べたいな
なんとしてでもあれ食べたいって執着が生まれる
例えば何か買い物を品物を見て買いたくなる
お金がない 苦しいでしょ
それで金に執着 あの瞬間で金があったらいいなという
執着が生まれてくる お風呂上がって体重計に乗ってみる
乗ってみたら結構合格
数字が多い 点数が高い
あーもっと痩せればいいなと体に対して執着が生まれる
鏡で顔を見る いろいろ見えますね
あまり明確に言いませんだけどね
その時も執着が生まれるんですね
それで例えばしわ見たりあれ見たりすると横から見るんですね
あ こう見たら若く見えますよとかね
それからいつでもそこをみんなの横顔見えるように頑張っていくんです
そんなもんなんですよ
人生っていうのは だから
そういう風に 毎瞬 毎瞬
我々は何とか苦をごまかしをしているんでしょうし
その時存在に執着が生まれるっているんです
この読みに虚栄心話じゃないんですよ
すごい客観的 現実的なんですよ
例えば 私たちみたいに年取ってくると視力が衰える
文字が読めなくなる あー嫌だな
これはとそれとか思っちゃう
あれは執着なんですね
それで私も眼鏡屋さんに行って眼鏡を作ってもらう
眼鏡を作ってもらったら
また見えるようになりましたんだけど
それ楽しいんだけど だってずっと眼鏡かけっぱなしだからね
あー嫌だなという気持ちは消えるわけじゃないでしょうに
だからそういう風に まあ最初に例えばすねが伸びたとしましょう
女性には毎日やってますからね
私はもう思い出したらすねを切れますけどね
で 指を見たら 私も時々すねが伸びている
あ これはちょっとかっこ悪いし
体かいだりしちゃうとすごい危険でしょうし
そこで執着が生まれて
じゃあかっこよくすねを切ろうではないかというふうになってくるんです
そういうふうに 生きることに
存在に対する執着がその都度その都度生まれるんですね
執着のレベルが苦しみのレベルに合うんです
例えば すねが伸びただけでは強烈に執着は生まれませんね
お腹が空いただけでは
ご飯も目の前にあるんだからね
強烈な執着が生まれません
しかし 病院で人間ドックで
あなたの肺にはちょっと影が入ってますよと
ちょっとこれは疑い もう血液検査見たってもがんであるという恐れがありますと
もうちょっと調べましょうと言われた途端
もう倒れますね 怖くなっちゃって
その時は強烈な生きていきたいという執着が生まれるんです
もうわかりますね 苦しみ
次に執着 苦しみ 次に執着
例えば心臓発作を起こしちゃった
心臓発作を起こした途端
もうもう気がなくなっちゃって倒れますね
その時は恐ろしい恐怖感と執着が生まれるんです
それからなんとか治療して生き返ってもらう
もらうんだけど 医者がそれからいろんな決まりをつけてあげちゃう
あまり走ってはいけない
心臓に負担をかけてはいけない
あるいはずっと酸素ボンベを使ってくださいとかね
そういう風にいろんな苦しみが足してきますね
苦しみが足してくるたびに執着が生まれていきます
生きていきたい 生きたいという
だから お医者さんたちは本当にかわいそうな仕事をしていますよ
人間が執着を丸出しにしている時なんですね
すごいかっこ悪い時なんですね
あ こんにちは お元気ですか？とかではないんで
その時は わがままやりたい放題の時
なぜかというと 患者さんがもう死にかけているんですね
苦しんでるんですね 苦しみのレベルに合わせて
執着のメーターが上がったり下がったりなんです
ちょっと立っていて ちょっと疲れたなと思ったら
少々の執着なんですね
座りたいなと それでわかりますかね
苦しみと執着の関係 だから
ちょっと自分の人生実験してみると
これ発見できます はい
2番目に行きます ちょっと時間取りすぎ
自分自身が作った鎖で煩悩束縛されて自由はない
それで人間には自由がないということです
命に対する執着こそが自分の罠なんですね
これが罠なんです なんで苦しみに執着するんですかね？これって屁理屈でしょ
我々この屁理屈やってるんです
だからお釈迦様が生命には理性がないんだよと
嫌なもんだったら嫌なこっちゃやと諦めるのは正しいでしょ
自分が飼ってる犬がもう絶え間なく吠えちゃうし
周りに迷惑かけるし その上自分にも噛みつくんと
どうします？その時 あーかわいいワンちゃんという気持ちがなくなっちゃうんですね
こいつは捨てようか どこかでということになっちゃうんです
だから 嫌なものだったら諦めるのは理性的なんですけど
私たちは自分の命はいつでも嫌なんですけど
それに屁理屈で もう理性的ではなくて
執着 執着 執着 ガンだと言われたら
もうなんで世の中でこのがんに対する治療方法が現れないのでしょうかとかね
遺伝子改良でもしてがんを治すことをできないのかと考えちゃうんです
がんになるからだったら放っておけなんですよ
答えは 関わるなよと これできないでしょうに
で 理由は知らないのに死ぬことが大嫌い
怖い 理由は知らないでしょ？なんで死ぬのは怖いかと
五感に刺激を与えることで生きられるという勘違い
妄想にふけることで楽しみが得られるという勘違いで
執着がさらに強くなっていく
生きる苦しみはさらにひどくなる
そこで我々は五感 目 耳
鼻にずっと刺激を与えるんですね
ああ これって楽しいやと勘違いしている
それから妄想するんですね
実現できないものは何でも妄想しちゃうんです
これ楽しいやと思ってるんですね
そういうことであの執着を増やしていくんですね
あの あの前 あの流行っていたか
今もディズニーチャンネルで放送していますけどもね
スパイダーマンとかね
スーパーマンとか あれやこれやとかね
子供向きのもうスーパーヒーローたちのプロ版映画とかね
あれって何ですかね 現実できないものは妄想で
実現して調子に乗ろうではないかという極端な愚か者の行為なんです
そういうことで生きることはさらにひどくなるんです
で 生命の生きる衝動は存在欲と怯えと無知です
そこで我々は支配しているのは存在欲
怯え それから無知 無知っていうのはもう理性がないんですね
皆様知っている言葉で言えば
貪瞋痴なんですね 生きる目的はない
知らない 貪瞋痴の衝動で仕方がなく生きる戦いをする
生きる目的っていうのは
科学的に調べてもないんです
ただ生まれたんだから生きているだけなんです
では何で生きているのかというと
生きていなきゃ苦しくてたまらんです
ご飯食べなかったら苦しくてたまらんです
呼吸しなかったら苦しくてたまらないんです
だからやってますね だから生きているんですね
何の尊い目的も何もないんですね
ただ単に貪瞋痴で生きろ生きろと言っているだけです
我々は何をしても 何を信仰しても
何を開発しても それはただ貪瞋痴の命令に従っているだけです
何やったっても すべて貪瞋痴の命令なんですね
自由はない 奴隷です 自由になる方法も知らない
はい  3番目 幸福を目指して不幸の方向へ進む
目指すのは 幸福ですが
得るのは空のみです 幸福という言葉の意味も理解していないんです
幸福って何ですかね？理解していないんですよ
だから正しく言えば苦しみが欲しくない
苦しみがない状態と理解した方がいいんだけど
それは言わない 誰も あの興奮した状態は幸福やと思いますね
ではないんです 現実的に自分が苦しんでるんです
この苦しみがなかったらいいなと思った方が正しい幸福の定義なんですね
これはあまり使ってないんです
だから我々は金があれば幸せ
結婚する相手がいれば幸せ
子供がいれば幸せ 立派なマイホームがあれば幸せ
昨日聞いた友達があれば幸せ
有名人になれば幸せとか
あるわあるわ幸せのことをいっぱい
あんなもんで苦しみだけなんです
ひどい目に遭うだけなんです
束縛が増えるだけなんです
例えば すごい人気者になったとイメージしてください
歩けないんですよ 外で
ですから大変ですよ すごい有名人になったら
ちょっとした店に行くこともできなくなっちゃうでしょ
これ楽しいんですかね
隠れて奴隷みたいに生活するの
結局はもう我々は幸福になろうと思って苦しみを作る
お釈迦様はアリエパリーサンスッタンタという中部経典で
これをずっと明確に説かれているんですね
で 苦しみをなくすために苦しみを作るものを求めるんだと
だから愚者の探求ですね
何がというと まあ財産
動物 家畜動物 家族 名誉などなどなんですね
そういうものから苦しみが生まれるんですよ
自分の子供が病気になったら
へっちゃらの気持ちでいられると思いますかね
自分の子供が何か事故でもしたら冷静でいられる？どのほど苦しみかと
だから苦しみは得体知れない人がやってくれるわけじゃないんですよ
例えば ザンビアの何々さんが死にましたと
車にはねられて 全然いたこもかゆくもないんですね
あなたの子供が 息子が車にはねられて死んじゃったよと言ったらどうですかね
どういう風な苦しみですかね
それは だから明確なんですね
私は幸せだと思って得たものが
私に苦しみを作っているんですね
貪瞋痴に束縛に煩悩に人質にされているので
生きるとは人質犯人に身代金を払っているだけです
我々は貪瞋痴に人質にされてます
それで貪瞋痴があれこれこれこれで要求するんです
刺激をくれと あれずっと刺激を与えているんです
身代金も払っているんです
人質にされたら そいつをぶん殴って逃げればいいのに
それはやってないんです
誘拐犯人の機嫌を取ったら
誘拐犯人がさらに凶暴になるだけなんです
しかし 無知なる心の要求に絶対死にたくはないという応じることが不可能な希望です
この我々は 我々の自由は誘拐されています
貪瞋痴に 私は今 脳のことをよく使いますから
原始脳に誘拐されていますよ
大脳皮質は これで原始脳の要求する身代金は絶対死なないことなんです
絶対死にたくない 徹底的に敵を倒してくれと
これは応じられませんね
だから宗教やら財産やら
いろんなもので機嫌を取ってあげるんです
ご飯食べたら死にませんよとかね
マイホームあったら安全だよとかね
結婚すればあんた人生は安全だよとかね
そうやってまあ原始脳を誤魔化してるんです
しかし 原始脳が期待する身代金金を払ってないんだから
自由にはならないんです
というわけで いくら頑張っても心は自由にならない
無常であり 苦であり この世に依存しても結果は苦が増えることだけです
幸福から遠ざかる道です
私たちは幸福から遠ざかる道を歩んでいるんです
お釈迦様はちょっと待ちなはれと
百八度道 生きる道変えなさいと
こちらに幸福がありますよと
これはお釈迦様以外誰も説かれてないんです
お釈迦様の仏教は宗派に分かれて
大乗やらやらとか 部派仏教とかね
分かれて分かれていった時も元に戻ったんです
原始のに ご利益とかね
祈祷とかね そういうものに悟りくはないやとかね
諦めましょうよとかね
堂々と言うようになっちゃったんです
だから私はいつでも釈迦尊の教えと世の中のすべての教えというのは両方分けて
仏教も含むんです  2つに分けて説明しているんです
はい 4番目に行きましょう
まあ全部出ました で 生命は老いること
病に陥ること 死ぬことを嫌がる
怖がる 怯える しかし 解決策はありません
精神的に弱くなっているんですね
いろんなことに怖がるんですけど
気が弱い人は他人の助けを求める
他人に助けられて生きていることは現実です
それにはリミットがあります
私たちはこの生老病死が怖いんで嫌ですね
で 怖いんですね 怯えてるの一種でも
で 精神的に弱くなっているんですね
どうしようかわからないんですね
それで じゃあ何かに助け頼りましょうとするんです
助けてくれと なんでそういう失敗するのかというと
日常の生き方っていうのは助けてもらって生きているんですね
いつでも 子供の人生を見ると
必ず親に助けられて生きているんですね
親が助けてあげないと
あのやんちゃぶりはできないんですね
我々大人もいろんな人々が助けてくれているんだから
元気で生きているんですね
皆様 こちらで呑気な気分でいるときは
皆様の家に泥棒が入ったらどうしますかね
もう入れませんよ そんな悪い人間はいません
だから安心していられるんでしょうに
だから自分の家に泥棒が入ってないっていうことも
やっぱり自分のことは大事にしているんだっていうことですよ
これ人のものだから まあ放っておきましょうよと
そういうふうに我々は助けられて生きているんですね
これ現実です しかし 助けられてもらうということにはリミットがありますよ
何でもかんでもできるわけじゃないんです
この気持ちは暴走して得体の知れない絶対的な存在に助けられると
盲信して落ち着くようにするのです
そういうことで神が世に現れてくるんです
自分の力を諦めているんです
救ってもらおうということで
他人が助けてくれると思うことは気休めだ
です 不安をなくすための自己暗示です
大丈夫 大丈夫 阿弥陀様が
あるいは観音様がついてるんだと
今日私は笑っちゃったんですけど
お釈迦様のお祭りですけど
踊りの方々はアヴァロキテシュバラという
得体知れない誰かを礼をする踊りでしたけど
歌はね サンスクリット語か何か
歌は全部私はわかりましたからね
何語かよくわかりませんだけど
全部私に まあインドの言語だから理解できましたけどね
私はターラって何やろうかと
観音って何やろうかと
もうブッダはこちら目の前にお釈迦様がいるのにね
やっぱりそれはネパールの踊りですからね
ネパール信仰ですからね
それは別に悪口言ってるわけじゃないんだけど
やっぱりそういうふうに人間がやっぱり滑ってしまうんですね
これって自己暗示なんですよ
観音様がついてますよと言うと
自己暗示でなんとなく安心するんですね
だからそれはそれで構わないんだけど
それが答えじゃないんですよ
痛いのは痛いのは飛んでいけと言っちゃうと
なんとなく気分がいいんだけど
痛みは飛んでいかないんですよ
私は今も思ってるんですね
小さい時 私は 3歳と上よりは上やと思ってるんですけど
弟がいてね 弟は赤ちゃんで
子供で いつでも母に甘えてもらったりして
これはすごく嫌なんですね
なんで弟だけ甘えてあげているのに
私のことはなんで甘えてくれないのかっていうね
嫌な気持ちあったんだけど
それでちょっとでも弟が泣いたりすると
痛いの痛いの飛んでいけということを母親やっちゃうんですね
大丈夫 大丈夫 なんとかなんとかとかね
はい 行っちゃったとかね
それであの弟がもう泣き止めちゃうんですね
私もなんかもうよくこけたり
よく怪我したりとかもうそっちゅうだけど
よく自分で我慢するんですね
じゃあ今度は甘えてやるぞと言って
ギャーと泣いちゃったんですね
それで お母ちゃんもういいさよと言ったら
同じことやっちゃったんですね
お母さんはやっぱり 痛いの痛いの飛んでけ
言われると まあ私にもやってくれるんだなという楽しみもあったんだけど
あら 飛んでいかないなとか
痛いのは飛んでいかないんですね
ただ 母親が心配してくれることはすごい気分がいいんですね
それだけ だから大人にいい大人になって
我々いまだに痛いのは痛いのは飛んでいけ
人生で生きてるんだからね
お釈迦様 こんな自己暗示をもうやめたらどうですかと
はい  5番目に行きます
自分が作った束縛を足すことで自由を得る
智慧が生じる 生きるとは体に感覚機能があることです
では 医学的にいきましょう
肉体の中に感覚機能がファンクションがあるんです
体の感覚によって自分がいる
自我があるという錯覚が生じるんですよ
これ 錯覚です 体を分解して細胞単位で見ると
何か触れたら感じるだけなんです
何も自我があるわけじゃないんです
でも 私たちは自分がいるという実感がやっぱりあるんですね
あれは錯覚なんですね
自我の錯覚に執着する
肉体ではなくて あの錯覚に執着しているんですよ
肉体に執着したら手術してもらわないでしょ
体の何かが悪くなっちゃったら
取り なんていうのは取り除いたりするでしょ
体に執着すると それは絶対やりませんね
やらせません だからはっきり言えば
肉体は悪いところだったら取ってくださいと頼んでるんです
自我に執着しているんですね
錯覚に 現実的に 肉体に
感覚に 思考 妄想に執着することですが
それには気づきません
だから 科学的に見ると
我々は肉体にというよりも感覚に執着しているんですね
この感覚はいい この感覚は嫌
例えばお腹が痛くなってくると感覚なんですね
この感覚は嫌というところで執着が生まれるんですね
すべての束縛が生きて生きたいという存在欲と
死にたくないという恐怖感から現れる
それで束縛されますね
だから生きていきたいのは私でしょうに
恐怖感もあるのは私でしょうに
だったら自分で掘った穴に落ちろということになってるんです
だから我々は自分でもう手錠をかけているんです
すべての束縛が 自分の気持ちは
自分の気持ちは自分を苦しみの中心系にしているんです
だから生きていきたいという私の気持ちは
私を中心系にしているんです
あなた中心系だと 中心系というのは日本語の単語がないんだから言ったんですけど
まあ輪廻なんですね 死んじゃっても同じ中心系なんです
解脱しない限りは 執着を捨てること
ありのままに真理を認めること
はですね はとてもことでなんか間違ってます
執着を捨てること ありのままに真理を認めることはとても楽になります
認めることで ん？認めると
認めるととても楽になります
あ こんなもんやと認めると
あーほっとするんですよ
それが幸福なんです あるお母さんがね
冷蔵庫になんか看板書いて貼ってるんだと私に言いましたけどもね
かなり完璧主義のお母さんで
結構ストレス溜まってるんですね
それで私はどこかで講演で言った
人間っていうのは不完全だと
みんな だから何よと そんな気にすることはないんだよと
その一行気に入っちゃって
なんか私は不完全です
だから何？と書いてある
貼ってあるんです 冷蔵庫に
で それで私はあれ 自己暗示じゃないんです
あれは事実です 毎日子育てにあれやこれやとかね
完璧主義者だからね 一生懸命やってますけど
まあうまくいかない時もありますよね
それでだから何よと 私は完璧じゃないんだから
ということで気楽なんですよ
そういうことで 楽になりますよ
執着を捨てると 生きるとは瞬間的に
また因縁によって成り立つ一時的な現象に過ぎないのだと発見することは智慧です
執着は無意味だと それでわかります
あの智慧っていうのはいたって簡単です
すべて瞬間瞬間で消えていくんだと
あ なるほど その通りやとわかることなんです
これにはちょっと瞑想する必要があります
瞬間っていうのは短い時間だからね
だから精密に集中して体と心を見ると
生まれては消える 生まれては消える
生まれては消える おっかないんですね
このスピードは あ こんなもんかと発見すると
もう智慧なんです そうすると自分のこと
こんな阿呆 これに執着する阿呆がいるのかい？という気持ちになるんですね
そこで無執着の心が生まれてくるんです
次の瞬間で解脱の心が現れるのです
はい  6番目 ですから 智慧こそが唯一の財産なんです
無知に基づいて生命は生きています
人間の知識さえも貪瞋痴の衝動で現れるものです
幸福をもたらせるものではありません
正しい生き方 正しい生きる目的を発見するためには
無知ではなく智慧が必要です
今はダメです 今無知で生きているんだから
だからやっぱり無常を発見することになるんですね
わずかな知恵でも人に自由と安らぎを与えます
知らないのは不安 知ると安心なんです
だからね  電車が止まったらアナウンスがないとえらいイライラするでしょう
電車が止まったことでアナウンスが流れるんですね
なんとかなんとか信号で停止しているんだと
あるいは人身事故で車
電車が止まりましたと言うと
苦しみが消えてないんだけど
なんとなくああ そうかということを諦めつくでしょ
で 見てください 日常俗世間でも我々はこの知ることの自由を味わってますよ
自分が家に戻れたく電車に乗っちゃったんだけど
人身事故で電車止まっちゃったんですね
人身事故やと言ったら
どうしよう じゃあ別な方法で行こうかなと
何もないんですよ だから知恵っていうのはすごく安らぎを与えるんですよ
こういう風に皆様は科学者みたいにもの徹底した現実主義者になってほしいっていうのは
ブッダの世界なんです
必死で不幸を目指して苦労する人間には
智慧があるならば 真の幸福を目指す方向へ生き方を変えることができます
で 世にある財産も親しい人々も
自分から離れる自分のものではありません
この世の中の何一つも私のものではありません
この肉体も私のものではありません
すべて一時的に 一時的に
ちょっと貸してもらって使っているだけ
幸福をもたらす智慧は自分自身なんです
智慧というのは自分自身なんです
自我ではないんです 自我は錯覚
その代わりには智慧を開発するんです
智慧は自分自身 それで幸福になるんです
智慧に勝る財産はありません
ということで はい  7番目に行きます
一切は因縁によって現れて
因縁によって消えます
じゃあスピードを上げましょう
一定のもの 一定なもの
変わらないものなどは存在しません
今 智慧の見方教えているところ
智慧があると どのように世の中が見えるのかと
智慧があるとこのように見えます
すべて因縁だよと 因果法則だよと
原因があって現れた 原因があって現れた
原因が消えたら消えるんだよ
だからそんなに困らなくてもいいんじゃないかと
何にでも原因があります
原因がなくなったら消えるだけで
まあ放っておけばいいんです
だから一定のものはないんです
だから困るべきことに値するものはないんです
何もないんです ああ 心配だわと言ったっても
そんな値するものはないんです
ああ 不安だわと言ったってもね
何が不安ですか？ないんです
そんなの 智慧で見ると不安では
何ですか？あなたの不安はと
やっぱり会社の将来が不安だと
こんなのは無常だから
別に珍しくなんでもないでしょうに
だから智慧で見ると せいせいまあへっちゃらですね
無常たる現象に執着するとは
蜃気楼を追いかけるようなもの
我々 あ 何 あ うん はい 蜃気楼を追いかけるようなもの
我々は蜃気楼を追いかけているんですよ
執着しているんだから取れないんですよ
無常だから 例えばシャボン玉を大事に持って家に持っていって
置き物として楽しめることできますかね
できないでしょうに あの蜃気楼はすごい派手でかっこいい
私は持っていきますと
馬鹿を見るだけなんですよ
だから我々は毎日そういう風にシンプル
新規を追ってるんですよ
執着があるから老いることも
病も死も悲しいのです
財産がなくなることも
嫌な人と好き 嫌な人と好きあるじゃなくて付き合うことも
好きな人と別れることも悲しいんです
執着あるんだから 執着を持って生きることは
ザルで水を汲むような無駄な行為です
一般人はザルで水を汲んでいるんですよ
だからいくら汲んでも水がないんです
喉が渇いたまんまなんです
だから 仏典ではいろいろお釈迦様がいろんな人と対話すると
このような話を対話しているんです
私には財産ありと威張っている人にお釈迦様
私には財産がなし だから安らぎですと
相手が私には財産あり
だから安らぎですと そういう風にも対話させちゃうんですね
一切の悩み苦しみは執着が原因です
心から執着という成り立たない感情
いわゆるいい加減な妄想ですよ
感情を取り除くことで
やっと真の幸福が現れます
はい 究極の幸福は今この世で体験するもの
これも釈尊の独特なポイントなんですね
無知も執着も今あるのです
今 私に無知がある 今 私に執着がある
全部今なんです 過去はもうないんですからね
将来も存在しないんだからね
今なんですね 今執着がある
今怒りがある 今欲がある
今無知がある 他気にすることないんです
今の自分を見ればいいんですよ
難しくないんです 前も説明しましたからね
すごい胸が痛くて ものすごくもう倒れそうになってくると
存在欲が今生まれてくるんです
心は貪瞋痴の衝動で働いているから
野生的なんですね 我々の心は
現実をありのままに ありのままの真理を教えてあげることで
野生的な心が成長します
心は野生なんですけど
原始脳なんですけど 教えられることはできます
現実はこういうものであると
宗教が約束する永遠の楽園は
死後得るものです 本当にあるかないかは確かめる方法
さえもありません しかし
心の成長は今行うべきです
だから あまりにもお釈迦様はリアリストなんですよ
あまりにも極端なリアリストなんです
現実主義者なんです 今ですよ
この瞬間だよと 永遠の楽園とか
こんなのは将来だから存在しないんだと
だって過去も存在しないでしょうに
そういう風に見ているんです
だから 今怒りがある 今欲がある
今無知があるということで
今執着がある 今束縛がある
今のあるものを取ってみましょうと
ですから 心成長することは今の仕事なんですね
執着をなくすことは安穏であると確かめてみることはできます
だから ちょっとやってみれば
あ これが楽だとわかるんですよ
だから ちょっとちょっと執着を捨ててみる
例えば離婚して悩んでいる
で 離婚された相手に対してまだ執着があるんですよ
もう別れたんだから 今更悩まなくてもいいでしょう
そこでまあその人を忘れちゃう
まあさようなら まあいいやと
二度とも会いたくはないんだと
そこで執着捨てたら まあ気分爽快で新たに頑張れるんですね
だから そういうふうに実験してみてください
だからといって離婚しないでください
そういう ただ例で出しただけで
他のことで 例えばね 中学校の高校生の時
例えば写真とかアルバムとかね
大事に保管してるでしょ
あれは自分にとって意味があるんだけど
息子にも孫にも全然興味ないんだからね
でも自分が捨てたくないでしょ
ああ 私はこれに執着している
これは過去ですと もう死んじゃったと
執着捨てますと 見てください
で あれ捨ててみてください
気分が楽になります すごい現代の人間になります
過去の死体を背負わない
執着をなくすとは 次 ブッダの教えはを少々実践してみても
人生は楽になるのだと各自で確かめてみることです
お釈迦様が私の話を信じなさいよ
汝らは死後天国に行けますよとおっしゃってないんです
今やってみなさい 確かめてみなさい
本当かないかと というのは
ブッダの特色で 他誰もそういうことを言ってないんです
方法は精密に説かれているので
完全たる心を作ることが誰にでもできます
ので お釈迦様は科学者だから
方法は精密に 全く間違いなく完全に説かれているんです
この法輪を使っているのは
輪っかは完全なんですね
でないと輪っかにならないんですよ
ブッダの教えは法輪というんですね
だから やってみれば誰でも悟りに達します
蜂はいましたね ブッダの教えは薬に例えられます
で 病で苦しんでいる人に適切な薬を推薦する
その人は薬を服をする服用することで病が治ります
病気が治ったと先に知るのは医者ではなく患者本人です
これは知っているでしょう
自分が病気になったら
お医者さんが薬を推薦して
自分は薬を服用していたら病気が治りますね
それで医者がもう一度診断して
汝の病気が治りましたと判子を押してくれる？くれません
病院に行かないです 病院に行かないで先生
約束して なんでまた来たんですか？と
病気はしっかり治しましたから
先生の薬のおかげで だから病気治りましたと
ちょっと判子押してくださいとは行かないでしょ
そういうことで ブッダの道をやってみたら幸福になります
誰も反抗する必要はないんです
これは自ら確かめる教えだとも言います
ですから 仏教は自ら確かめる教えだと言いますね
人類が正しい束縛を探していることに対して
サクソンは自由を推薦します
人類は正しい束縛を探していますよ
正しい神を探しているんです
何に頼ればいいやと お釈迦様頼るなよと
自由になりなさいと言っているんです
釈尊の教えに 似た教えはこの世に存在しない
ブッダの教えに古くなることはない
改良する必要はない 唯一完全な教え
これはもう世の中にはありえないんですよ
すべて不完全だから だから一つだけブッダの教えだけ完全なんです
釈尊に真理を発表するとき
釈尊は世に真理を発表するとき
決まって繰り返し繰り返し使ったフレーズがあります
アヌッタランダンマチャッカンパワッティタン アッパティワッティヤン サマネーナワ ブラーマネーナワ デーヴ
ェーナワ マーレーナワ ブラームナーワ ケーナチワローカスミン
これは初転法輪経だけではなくて
いくつかのところでもこのフレーズが出てくるんです
意味は この上のない法輪
いわゆる真理の法則ですね
を発表しました それは逆転させることは
いかなるシャモンにも
いかなるバラモンにも
いかなる神にも いかなる魔にも
いかなる梵天にも 他のほかどの存在にも不可能ですと
ここまで大胆に発言できますかね
人間には  2557かける
わからない もう多数ですからね
で こんな大胆な言葉で語ったんです
できることならやってみなさいよと
どんな神にも どんな宗教者にも
どんな知識人にも どんな悪魔にも
私の教えは間違っているんだよと言えませんよと
いまだにその通りなんです
これ獅子空とも言いますけどね
大胆な発言です 大胆な挑戦です
一切の生命の知識に 能力にチャレンジしています
ブッダはすべての知識人に
2557年経った今でも
この挑戦に応えられる人はいません
だから真剣に だから信頼できる教えです
はい 間違いがあるならば言いなさいという調子で語られた教えです
世界が発展して 知識が発展して
昔の間違いは直されている
現代でもブッダの教えは輝いているのです
訂正するべきところはないのです
ですから ブッダの言葉こそが唯一信頼できる教えです
釈尊が一切の生命の中で唯一信頼できる方です
現代知識では理解するのは難しいところもあるかもしれませんが
確信を持って実践できるのです
確かめられるのです どんな人間にも適した実践方法
アドバイスはブッダの言葉にあります
そういうことで 今日のお話を終了します
どうもありがとうございます
私はテーラワーダ仏教会員になり
一年経ちました 男性 歳になります
この方が毎日一つずつ涅槃の瞑想とヴィパッサナー瞑想をしています
YOUTUBE でどう書かれていたでしょうか
あるお坊さんのビデオを聞いていたところ
今のヴィパッサナー瞑想のやり方では禅宗の如く悟ることは困難かのように言われていましたが
どのようにしたらいいのでしょうか
という質問です  あまり聞き取れなかった
初めから大丈夫です  大丈夫らしい
あるテーラワーダの日本人の坊さんが
今のスマナサーラが教えているヴィパッサナーのやり方では禅に達しないので悟ることは難しいという風に言っていたそうです
私も知っている人です
どのようにこれは会員の方が修行していて
ちょっとそういうものを見てしまって迷ってしまっているということなので
禅定に達してないから
どうしたらいいのでしょうか？という
要するに方法に対する
ああ だからまあ私は教えてるヴィパッサナー法っていうのはないんですけどね
私は精密に経典に基づいてお釈迦様がおっしゃったのを教えてるだけで
お釈迦様の教えで悟れないというならば
まあどうぞさようなら
大丈夫  よし うん 次は歳 の女性の方です
もうちょっとマイクの聞こえるように
歳 の女性の方 私はいつも自分に自信がなく
人の目評価を気にしすぎたり
人と比べて落ち込んだりしてしまいます
どうしたらもっと自分に自信を持って明るく生きられるでしょうか
うん まあこれは誰でもね
自分に自信がないしね
我々原始ののあれで衝動で生きてますからね
まあ貪瞋痴で生きて自我を作っていると
自分がまあやっぱり世界対自分でしょ
だから世界対世界に対自分だからね
もう自信が消えちゃいますよ
だからこれすごい病気にもなりますね
とは言っても 誰でもそんなもんなんですよ
自分に自信がないっていうことでね
だからまあこれはね 脳を開発してほしいんですね
感情ではなくて 現実的に生きてみるということなんですね
だから現実的に生きてみると
自信があるないっていうのは関係ないんですよ
例えば子供二人が走る
で 一人が足が弱く遅くて二番目になる
だからといって自信がなくなる必要ないでしょうね
それ現実ですからね だから二人で私の足が遅い
君の足が速い それで終わりでしょ
話は ものすごい 自分がもうもうお茶飲んでるところに
ある人が来る ある女性が
これかなり美人で もうかなりかっこよく
服装で体をデザインしている
自分がそこら辺に家にあったものを着て
喫茶店に行っただけなんですね
あの瞬間で自信が消えちゃいますね
ああ まずいやと 私はこの人ほどもう痩せてないんだとかね
いろいろとね まあいいじゃねえか
そんなもんで まあ現実ですからね
私はお化粧してないよ
今日はとかね まあ料理終わってからそのまま来ただけばっかしやと
言ってゲラゲラ笑っちゃえばいいんです
今もう香水のところが指が臭いんですよ
食べ物の  それで楽なんですよ
だから人の目を気にするんじゃなくてね
まず人の目を気にするということは間違いですね
自分は自分 自分と二流天才はいません
だから 自分が自分の体と心をどう働かせるのかっていうことなんですね
ロバは馬にならないでしょ
ロバは馬のことを見て馬ってかっこいいなあとかね
背が高くていいなあとかね
ロバにも一応あれなんて
またたてがみみたいなもんがあるんだけど
ちっぽけなもの かっこ悪いんですよ
それに比べたら馬のたてがみなんかはね
かっこいいんでしょ ロバが馬を見て自信がなくなってどうするんですかね
お前いいロバになれだけでしょうに
で なんでロバのたとえを使ったかというと
我々の文化ではロバっていうのはバカって意味なんですね
英語でもアースっていうのはね
バカって意味で使うんですね
インド文化でも同じですね
だからロバが馬を見て馬になりたいなとかね
もう言うんじゃないんですよ
我々は 私は私で 私に似ている人はいません
だから自分が自分なりに生きてみれば
それで十分ですよ 例えば
自分が喋るとどもっちゃうと
いいじゃないか それで
それで結構です そういうことで
私たちは人の目を気にするということは
自分でも生きられない
とんでもない恐ろしい負いを作ることなんですね
道徳的に人に迷惑をかけない程度で十分です
と言っても 人に迷惑をかけなきゃ生きていられませんでしょ
人に迷惑をかける場合も
それはよく覚悟の上で
迷惑をかければいいんです
これこれやってくださいよとかね
あんたはやりたくないのはよくわかってますけど
やりなさいよとかね  そういうふうに
まあ自分なりの生き方
自分のドラマの台本を自分で作らなくちゃあかんですね
まあみんなにある弱みなんですね
人の目を気になるというね
女性には多いように言われますけど
男性にも結構それありますよ
だからまあ 自分は自分で
これ自分は自分でいいと言っても
これをわがままでいいわけじゃないんです
自分は自分でどのようにこの世と合致して生きるのか
といわゆる自分がどのように役に立つのかと
それだけ考えましょう
何か 1個 2つぐらいできることあるでしょう
それで十分です 人間は多才能で生まれませんね
このウェーサーカ祭りを用意するときでも
みんな全部できるわけじゃないで
今回も前の年もね 花屋さんがこの前はそうじゃなくて
教会のメンバーたちが派手に舞台上いっぱい花を作っちゃったんですけどね
そこでもうその方が今は日本でいないし
だからまあ教会のメンバーたちがね
もう我々には花できませんだからということで
花屋さんに頼んじゃったんですね
頼んだ結果はそんなもので
だからそれどういうことかというと
ボランティアで協力した方々には美しく花を立てる才能はなかったんで
だから別にそれで文句言う必要もない必要も落ち込む必要もないでしょうに
料理作る人は料理作るわ
まあ後片付けできる人は後片付けは
挨拶できる人は挨拶するわというこういう感じで
自分のできることを貢献する
あれもやりたい これもやりたいんだけどできないなというふうに悩む必要はないんですね
はい  はい 次は男性の方ですね
ちょっと単面すぎる質問かもしれませんが
与える生き方ということで
他人に与えるようにしているつもりなのですが
あまり喜んでもらえません
どうも相手によっては私から何かをもらったり
何かをしてもらいたくないようです
全くの他人であればそれも仕方ないと思いますが
親兄弟であってもそのような態度です
また 何かをしたところで
それが本当に相手のためになっているかどうかわかりません
相手が本当にしてもらえることとしてもらいたいこととは思いません
相手が本当にしてもらいたいことを私が与えることができないというふうに書いてありますね
自分という人間が他人にできることがなさすぎて気力がなくなります
という悩みです  で 物質的なことを考えているようだと思いますけどね
まあ家族兄弟なんかに何かあげちゃえばいいんだっていうね
向こうはそれが良くないんですよ
人間は一人一人自分の力で生きていなくちゃあかんですよ
だから 物質的に与えるということはちょっと考えた方がいいんです
まあ子供はね  18歳になるまではご飯食べさせてあげますけど 18
歳になったらやけに何かバイトしなさいと
お母さんが言わなくちゃあかんですね
バイトしてお母さんにも半分ぐらいあげなさいよ
で言われると子供は嫌がるかと嫌がらないんですよ
だから正しい生き方というのは
みんな自分の力で生きていなくちゃいけないんですね
だから この与える与えるという言葉だけに乗っちゃってね
与えたっても嫌われ者になるだけなんです
それから世の中で人からもらいたくばっかり狙ってる人々もいるんですね
だからそれも良くないんですね
そういう人々に与えたってもね
あの連中もずっとダメになっちゃうだけで
だからその2つでもないんですよ
与えるっていうことはね
世の中でみんな不完全だから
万能じゃないんだから
まあこれができてもこれができないということはありますね
そのできないところを与えてくれるんで
私も皆様にね もう助けられて
ものすごく喜びを感じたことがありまして
私は学生の時はお引っ越ししたかったんですね
でも私は整理整頓はものすごく下手で
どうやって部屋の荷物を運べるのかとわからなくなっちゃって
まあ途方に暮れちゃって
落ち込んちゃって それである友達にもう大変やと
今はこういうこと一個しなくちゃあかんだけどね
これできなくてと言ったら
なんのことなく まあいいや
もう車持ってきますからと言って
その人は車を持ってきて
バンバン荷物を全部運んじゃったんですね
車に ものすごく安らぎを感じたんですね
やっぱり友達っていうのはすごいもんだと
私はこんなに安らぎ感じるんだと
なぜかというと その人が私にできないことをおしつけてきてるんです
与えてるんですね それで逆に下手くそだとわかったんだから
新しい家にアパートに入ってから
バンバンまた入っちゃう
全部入れちゃって ここはこちら
ここはこちら ここはこちら
はい 悪いとこ入っちゃったんです
だからすごく助かりましたね
そういう風に 必死の時与えるものなんですね
だからそれをわからないんですよね
だからいつでも我々は慈しみの心でいましょう
それで十分です 慈しみの心でいると
すぐ見送っちゃうんですね
あの人にはこれが必要みたいやと
あの人は道に迷ってるんだとかね
すぐわかるんですね わかったらそこだけ与えると
それから本人が自立しなくちゃいけないんです
子供は大学卒業するまで親が面倒見てあげる
それから子供は自立しなくちゃいけないんです
自立しているのに いちいちあれやこれやとやることは侵害なんですね
だから勝手にあげたら嫌われますね
それから自分で努力するつもりは全くない人にあげる必要もないんです
といっても この世の中でね
やっぱり助けてあげなくては生きていられない人々も出ますね
例えば 障害を持って生まれるは
自分の生き方が悪いんだからね
まあ倒産しちゃってホームレスになってる人々もいるわとかね
やっぱり助けた方がいいでしょう
そういう場合でも適切に
摂生を見て助けてあげますよ
日本の大御所の方々でも
何でもかんでもやってくれるのは嫌なんですよ
それなりの人間としてプライド持ってますね
それは壊してはならないんですね
だから節度を散って なんとか助けてあげたりする
で そういう風に与えるということはね
結構大きい世界なんですね
で 与えたいでしょ 与えたいならば
まず慈悲の気持ちを育てましょう
一切の生命に対して そうなってくると
いくらでも見えてきます
自分の部屋に昆虫が入り込んだら
慈しみがあれば あ 昆虫さんが部屋に迷子になってきましたと
これではこの子は死んじゃいますよと
では助けてあげますと
そこで昆虫さんを外へ出してあげる
それも命を与えたことなんです
殺虫剤を持ってきてサーッとかけることじゃないんです
だから慈しみがあれば
で 私の菩提樹はいつでも病気で私と同じですね
もう出来が悪くて 成長も悪くて
もう腹が立ってますけどね
早く成長しろよって言ってるのに聞いてくれないしね
それはいいんだけど 時々どこから来るかわからないんだけど
小さな虫たちが出てくるんですね
で そうすると 私はもう菩提樹の葉っぱなんかに水をかけるのはやめちゃいますね
かわいそうだからね 虫たちは
あの植木鉢のところに丁寧に水をかけて
まあ結局家の中では困るでしょうと
あなた方を置いて菩提樹を外に置いておくんですね
置いておいてずっと見てるの
どうですか？こういつら元気でしょうかとかね
それでどうせ昆虫の命は短いんだから
またきれいに消えちゃいますね
またはどこかなく現れたりもする
わからない とにかく私は昆虫の菩提樹を
小さな虫たちに菩提樹を食べられて
とんでもないやつ これはないんですよ
菩提樹よりは生命の命は大事です
だからそれで何か与えることはできるようになっちゃうんですね
そういうふうに慈しみを育ててみると
結構チャンスが訪れますよ
ただ 私にはあります だからあなたにあげますというと
ちょっと態度はね 良くないんですね
で 仏教にブッダの教えを広めるためにお布施しなさいと言っているのは
それはもう断然的にもう役に立ちますから
なんですね 仏教伝道に協力したら
仏教は助かるわけじゃないんですよ
別に 私に至っても一人でいるのは楽なんでしょうし
国へ帰ってどっかの田舎のお寺で隠れていれば楽ですけどね
だから別に仏教が助かるわけじゃなくて
人類が助かるんですよ
たくさん日本の方々は仏教を応援する
別に何かあげなくてもいいんだけど
仏教を応援するということになっちゃうと
日本の社会で仏教っていうのはすごい力強くなっちゃうんですね
そうすると誰でも困った時はブッダのあの
信頼できるブッダの教えに頼ったりしますね
だからみんな性格はいいんですよ
ただ このメッセージが入ってないんですね
宗教嫌いという方々は性格も悪いわけじゃないんです
ただ 情報を知らない 間違った情報が入ったりして
そういうわけで ブッダの教えを広めるために協力してあげたり
ボランティアしてあげたり
苦労してみたりすると
これはものすごい布施になるんですね
で まあそのような感じで
まあいろいろ我々には見えてきます
慈しみを増す 育ちましょう
慈しみを育てると どこにお布施をすればよろしいかと
どんなお布施の方がよろしいかと
それを形変えて形変えて現れてきます
物質的なものをあげることだけではないんです
はい  ありがとうございます
では 時間が押してますので
最後に一問にしたいと思います
これも二十七歳の男性の方ですね
仕事で今までやったことのない大きな案件を任されています
他の人々が異なる意見を自分に言ってくる状況で決断をし
進めていく必要があります
できないかもしれないという不安やプレッシャーを乗り越えて
周囲の人々の役に立っていくには
どのような心構えで心構えが必要でしょうか
答え簡単でしょ 自分にできるから任せられたでしょ
信頼しているんだからね
それだけで それを裏切らないで
人の意見というよりは
やっぱり自分に任された仕事だからね
人の意見聞いたって失敗したって自分のせいになっちゃうしね
まあそういうところだけね
人の いわゆる先輩の経験者の意見は意見には耳を傾くべきですけど
まあ私にできるから任されたでしょう
あるいは私がこれからもっと成長するべきだから任されたでしょうと
だからあなたは若いしね
期待されてるんですよ
もうちょっと腕を上げてほしいと思ってるんですね
だから ちょっと厳しい宿題を出されているかもしれませんね
だから受けて立つしかないんです
はい  ありがとうございました
他にも質問をいくつかいただいておりますが
協会の力士の立川側の Q&A コーナーなどで反映させていただきたいと思います
それでは これにて上坂記念法話終了したいと思います
ありがとうございました
はい どうもありがとうございました